Sechs.
Sechs und drei. Eins, zwei, drei.
Jetzt musst du raus, Heinz Rüdiger. Vier.
So, jetzt bist du dran, Heinz Rüdiger. Ja, was ist? Komm, da wird anständig gewürfelt. Das Spiel heißt Mensch ärgere dich nicht.
Komm, jetzt spiel schön anständig.
Ja, was ist jetzt? Wer wird jetzt da gespielt oder nicht? Das musst du von der heiteren Seite her sehen. Das ist doch bloß ein Spiel. Also komm, da wird jetzt anständig gewürfelt. Ja, sag mal, hörst du schlecht? Du bist dran, Malefitz. Jetzt wer gewürfelt? Also, das sag ich dir. Wenn du jetzt nicht gewürfelst, dann würfel ich für dich. Hast du das gehört? Du ramm Papa nicht reizen.
Jetzt spiel schön ordentlich, sonst spielt der Papa für dich.
Na gut, dann würfel ich für dich. Du wirst sehen, jetzt hast du's gleich verloren. Und jetzt komm ich.
Und drei.
Eins, zwei, drei, ganz draußen.
Sag mal, spinnst jetzt du?
Du Rotzlöffel. Jetzt baust du's wieder auf, genauso wie es vorher war. Da wird anständig gespielt. Ja, wo sind wir denn?
Wir werden dir Spielen schon noch beibringen, du Malefitz. Das machst du nicht noch mal.
Und das sag ich dir, wenn wir jetzt nach Italien fahren, in Urlaub, wird dieses Spiel mitgenommen. Dann wird so lange gespielt, bis du den Ernst von dem Spiel mal begreifst.
Hallo, hier ist Chaos Radio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 162. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich lade euch ein und begrüße euch zu dieser Ausgabe, in der es wieder nicht um Hardcore-Computer-Technologie geht. Wer auch immer darauf gehofft hat, muss auch leider ein weiteres Mal enttäuscht werden, aber keine Angst. Wir werden es hier bald auch wieder ganz kompliziert werden lassen. Heute aber erst mal wieder ein kleiner Ausflug, nachdem ich zuletzt in Linz war, haben mich jetzt die Züge weitergetragen bis nach München. Und ja, heute geht es um was ganz Analoges, zumindest weitgehend. Es geht um Brettspiele. Ihr wisst schon, Steinchen auf Spielplänen und so weiter. Und da ich da wieder mal keine Ahnung davon habe, dachte ich mir, freue ich mich mal an Marcel. Hallo, Marcel.
Hallo Tim.
Oder voll ausgeschrieben Marcel-André Casasola Merkle.
Richtig.
Ein wuchtiger Name. Und deswegen heißt du im Netz auch Zeitweise.
Richtig, genau. Ist ein bisschen kürzer, kann man sich auch besser nennen.
Weißt du nur Zeitweise, Zeitweise oder immer?
Ich heiße Zeitweise, weil meine Abkürzung MACN nicht mehr verfügbar war. Und das war eigentlich eher so ein Unglück, was durch irgendeins dieser sozialen Netzwerke entstanden ist. Ich hatte nicht vor, so weiter zu heißen. Ist natürlich ein Problem, weil Zeitweise da findet man ja nichts, wenn man danach googelt. Solange Google kein Add versteht.
Verstehe. Ah, Google kann kein Add?
Ja, erkennt es nicht als Zeichen. Das wird ja rausgefiltert, so wie das Ö.
Oha, Schweinerei. Na, da beschweren wir uns nach der Sendung noch mal ordentlich drüber. Aber jetzt soll ich um was ganz anderes gehen. Nämlich um Brettspiele, wie schon angedeutet. Und warum bin ich da eigentlich jetzt bei dir gelandet? Du beschäftigst dich mit diesem Thema schon ein wenig länger. Seit wann denn eigentlich?
Also mit dem Thema beschäftigen, seit ich spiele. Und das ist schon sehr, sehr lange.
Seit der Kindheit nehme ich mal an, oder?
Seit der Kindheit, genau. Ich habe auch als Zehnjähriger oder so dann angefangen, tolle Spielpläne zu malen. Das waren dann normalerweise einfach bloß so Laufspiele. Also ich würfle, ich laufe, es passiert ein Ereignis, ich würfle, ich laufe. Also das, was eigentlich keinen Spaß macht, was wir aber alle kennen und vielleicht auch mit Brettspielen assoziieren.
Wie jetzt Laufen im Sinne von Straßenpflaster oder was?
Mensch, eier dich nicht, ist zum Beispiel so ein Laufspiel. Genau, Laufen auf einer Leiste, Felderleiste. Wir kennen da viele Spiele, Spiel des Lebens zum Beispiel.
Oh ja.
Genau. Das war so der Einstieg, dass ich einfach mal selber welche gebastelt habe, weil ich gedacht habe, hey, das kannst du auch. Das lustige ist, ich kenne viele, viele Menschen, die in ihrem Leben schon mal ein Spiel entwickelt haben. Also sei es sowas Albernes oder ein Quizspiel oder irgendein Spiel doof fanden und sich gedacht haben, das kann ich besser machen.
Warum kannst du die?
Wenn ich mit Menschen darüber spreche, also man kommt ja ins Gespräch. Was machst du so? Ich finde Brettspiele interessant. Ich habe hier auch noch was in der Schachtel. Dann kommt raus, dass es viele schon mal gemacht haben und dann natürlich nicht ernsthaft verfolgt haben.
Aber warum? Ich meine, was hat dich jetzt daran so fasziniert? Ich meine, Mensch ärgere dich nicht. Gut, das hat jetzt jeder mal so durch, aber so ein besonderes ist ja eigentlich mehr ein Glücksspiel, als dass man da jetzt mit Strategie dabei wäre oder so. Das hat mich eigentlich selbst immer ein bisschen abgeturnt. Spiel des Lebens, soweit ich das in Erinnerungen habe, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was da so besonders dran war. Das war da auch mal irgendwie maßlos erfolgreich, oder?
Ja, das Besondere daran war, dass es bei einem Verlag veröffentlicht wurde, der eine große Marktmacht hat. Das ist mittlerweile Hasbro. Es gab früher zwei Verlage in Amerika, Parker und MB. Die kennen wir alle, Parker von Nopoli, MB von dem Gong aus der Werbung. Das Kind mit dem Gong, kennst du nicht mehr? MB präsentiert, bumm bumm. Okay, das war nicht alles so im Kopf. Die wenigsten wissen, dass es jetzt ein Konzern ist, das ist Hasbro. Das ist der Player in Amerika, was Brettspiele angeht, auch weltweit der Player.
Und überhaupt Kinderspielzeug im weiteren Sinne, oder?
Die machen auch Spielzeug. Also Mattel zum Beispiel hat auch mal einen Ausflug ins Brettspiel gemacht, macht aber nicht mehr viel. Aber Hasbro macht eben noch viel Brettspiele und das sind die ganzen Klassiker, die wir kennen. Risiko, Monopoly, Cluedo, Spiel des Lebens, Hotel, Trivial Pursuit, diese ganzen Spiele, die einfach jeder kennt, weil sie überall im Laden stehen. Und das ist zugleich aber auch der Fluch von Hasbro. Viel Neues kommt dann nicht mehr, weil die versuchen, ihre alten Reihen zu pflegen. Gibt es dann halt ein Risiko Herr der Ringe und ein Risiko Simpsons und ein Risiko, wo man auf dem Kopf steht und was weiß ich, ein Risiko Cash and Money, wo dann noch so eine kleine Karte dabei ist, die man durch so einen Laser ziehen kann. Also alles Mögliche, die machen Produktpflege, aber Innovationen kommen eigentlich da nicht mehr her. Also Hasbro ist das McDonalds der Brettspiele, kann man schon sagen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die jetzt alle, also Cluido, das ist ein bisschen an mir vorbeigegangen. Ich weiß, dass es das gibt. Ist das was, was war denn? Ist das nicht so ein Detektiv-Ding?
Das ist so ein Deduktionsspiel. Also Deduktionsspiel ist ein ganzes Genre bei Brettspielen. Das heißt, man muss sozusagen Rätsel lösen, indem man Hinweise bekommt. Und dann das zusammen puzzeln und schauen, dass man eben herausbekommt, wer war der Mörder. Ich kriege dann einen Hinweis, ein bisschen wie so Doku. So Doku wäre ein Deduktionsspiel in dem Sinne. Also ich habe einfach Hinweise und kann mir aus denen die Lösung zusammenpuzzeln. Bei dem Spiel kriegst du natürlich nicht alle Hinweise auf einmal. Meistens ist es so was wie, wer war der Mörder? Der hatte einen Bart und der war dick. Und dann hast du halt verschiedene Leute, aus denen du auswählen kannst. Das ist oft trivial, aber es gibt auch sehr raffinierte Deduktionsspiele.
Aber Cluedo gehört jetzt nicht unbedingt dazu.
Cluedo nicht. Also Hasbro macht auch hauptsächlich Mainstream-Spiele, die wirklich auch von jedem gespielt werden können, von jedem auch gespielt werden. Also in jedem Haushalt gibt es mindestens ein Hasbro-Spiel, könnte man sagen. Der Witz ist natürlich, die meisten kennen gar nicht die original Spielregeln. Denn diese Spiele werden einfach tradiert. Das ist wie bei Märchen. Also da wird die Regel mündlich weitergegeben und man spielt halt so, wie man das gehört hat von seinen Freunden. Er hat oft gar nicht so viel damit zu tun, wie die Spielregeln wirklich sind.
Du meinst, die meisten Leute spielen die Spiele alle falsch?
Ja, die meisten Leute spielen die Spiele falsch. Schön ist, wenn ein Spiel dann trotzdem noch funktioniert.
Aber kann man da überhaupt so viel falsch machen? Ich meine, so bei Mensch ärgere ich nicht.
Bei Mensch ärgere ich nicht? Mensch ärgere ich nicht. Das ist ein ganz gutes Beispiel. Da kann man zum Beispiel spielen mit Wurfzwang. Das heißt, ich muss werfen, wenn ich die Option habe zu werfen. Man kann ohne Wurfzwang spielen. Man könnte auch spielen, ohne eine 6 zu würfeln, darf man direkt aus dem Haus gehen. Das sind Varianten. Was ist richtig oder falsch? Was am meisten Spaß macht, ist richtig. So simpel ist es eigentlich. Genau.
Und wie viele Kategorien unterscheidet man, wenn du jetzt schon so mit Deduktionsspiel daherkommst? Gibt es so 5 goldene Kategorien, die sich alles einteilen lässt?
Das ist sehr verquast. Es gibt Tausende von Kategorien, die oft nicht miteinander kompatibel sind, also die auf anderen Ebenen spielen. Also ich habe ein Deduktionsspiel, ich habe ein Strategiespiel. Ein Strategiespiel, wo Deduktion vorkommt, kann auch wieder beides mischen. Ich habe ein Kartenspiel, das bezieht sich darauf, welches Material ich habe. Also es gibt keine richtige Kategorisierung von gut abgetrennten Genres.
Das ist denn so das erfolgreichste Brettspiel von diesem ganzen Mainstream-Kram?
Das ist schwer zu sagen. Das sind solche Sachen wie Memory, Mensch, ärgere dich nicht.
Also Memory würdest du auch zu Brettspielen?
Ja, vielleicht ist es ganz gut, wenn wir das mal ein bisschen eingrenzen. Was sind Brettspiele überhaupt? Fakt ist, wir haben keinen vernünftigen Begriff dafür. Weil jeder Begriff ist falsch. Brettspiele sagst du ganz richtig, Memory hat doch nur Karten, ist kein Brettspiel. Gesellschaftsspiele, da denken manche Leute an Ringelpiz mit Anfassen. Was gibt es noch für Begriffe? Es gibt das Autorenspiel mittlerweile. Das grenzt dann eben ein auf Spiele, die von einem Autor, also wir nennen uns eigentlich Spieleautoren, ich sag gerne Spieleentwickler, das herkömmliche Wort ist Spiele-Erfinder. Also ich möchte es mal umreißen. Brettspiele sind Spiele, meisten Spiele, die in einer Box geliefert werden, wo ich zum Beispiel ein Brett habe, wo ich Karten habe, wo ich miteinander kommuniziere, wo ich ein festes Regelwerk habe. Was schließt es jetzt denn nicht mit ein? Also so ein Twister, das kennen vielleicht auch einige, das ist so eine Matte, auf der man rumhüpft und das was würfelt, das ist so ein Grenzbereich.
Weil es auch mehr um körperliche Aktivität geht und nicht so sehr ums Hirn.
Genau. Wobei, nein, das ist gar nicht unbedingt so zu sagen. Es gibt auch Brettspiele, die als solche bezeichnet werden können, wo es dann auch bloß um Aktivität geht, wo man in die Mitte klatschen muss mit einer Hand. Oder es gibt Eier-Tanz, da klemst du dir so Eier unter die Achseln und musst um den Tisch laufen. Irgendwie sind das auch Brettspiele. Im Grunde ist es so Fassi an den Rändern.
Um Eier sich unter den Arm zu klemmen, muss man sich ja keine Box für kaufen.
Doch, und zwar eine Eierbox. Wo dann Eier drin sind? Das sind so Gummi-Eier und ein Holzei.
Okay, was die alles gibt. Man hat so den Eindruck, dass die Fantasie mancher Leute doch erhebliche Nachhilfe braucht, um sich zu amüsieren.
Du meinst, Leute, die sich nicht amüsieren können, brauchen Brettspiel dafür. War das so in die Stoßrichtung gedacht?
Ja, ich tappe da ein wenig im Dunkeln. Ich selber habe natürlich auch Spiele gespielt, wie man sie jetzt auch nennen mag. Bei vielen dann auch wieder die Lust verloren. Aber manches finde ich einfach so albern und frage mich dann immer, wen denn das überhaupt dann noch begeistern kann. Ich stelle fest, dass diese Spiele selbst so wenig, es sind teilweise einfach nur so ein paar Hilfsmittel in Plastik, die man dann irgendwie bewegt. Das soll dann irgendwie so ein Spiel sein. Ich würde mich davon nicht besonders unterhalten fühlen.
Da sieht man dieses klassische Dilemma der Brettspielszene. Du hast genau dieses Bild, was eigentlich fast alle Menschen von Spielen haben. Das ist dieses 70er-Jahre-Hass-Pro-Bild. Plastik gedöhnt, kommt auf den Tisch und dann wird halt irgendwas da, so ein Nilpferd kann dann den Mund aufmachen und dann fallen da Kugeln rein. Die Sache ist die, die Brettspiele haben in den letzten 30 Jahren eine unglaubliche Entwicklung gemacht. Eigentlich verrückt, weil Brettspiele gibt es seit Urzeiten.
Würdest du jetzt eigentlich sowas wie Schach eigentlich auch als Brettspiel bezeichnen?
Ja, also Schach ist definitiv ein Brettspiel. Würde auf dem Markt vielleicht nicht so große Chancen haben oder eher eine Nische besetzen, weil es sehr, sehr schwierig ist, Schach gut zu spielen. Zum Beispiel, ich habe mich mit Schach auch kaum beschäftigt. Ich würde da wahrscheinlich Schwachsinn erzählen. Ich kenne nicht mal alle Regeln, wie die Rochade da funktioniert. Das sind aber Klassiker, also klassische Brettspiele.
Ja, so Halma und so, was nicht alles gibt. Hier Dame, Mühle.
Ja, und es gibt ja auch viele traditionelle Spiele. Also in jedem Land gibt es eigentlich traditionelle Spiele oder in jeder Region. Ob das jetzt Doppelkopf ist oder in Spanien Moose spielt man da oder Go oder Mayong in den asiatischen Ländern. Also jeder hat so traditionelle Spiele. Also Spiele sind tief verwurzelt in der Gesellschaft, aber es gibt nur sehr, sehr wenige und sehr, sehr wenige Klassiker. Die Entwicklung, dass es viele neue Spiele gibt, die hat eigentlich erst im letzten Jahrhundert begonnen. Hat natürlich auch was mit den Druckmethoden und so weiter zu tun, dass man die erst dann produzieren konnte. Aber mittlerweile gibt es eine wirklich große Bandbreite an verschiedenen Spielen. Und die sind wesentlich anspruchsvoller als das, was man eben so gemeinhin kennt, was man im Supermarkt kaufen kann. Und nicht nur anspruchsvoller, es gibt auch eine wahnsinnige Bandbreite. Es geht nämlich von dem Aktionsspiel, wo ich einfach auf dem Tisch klatschen muss, über das kreative Spiel, wo ich vielleicht was malen kann, über das Quizspiel, wo ich was wissen muss, über das Strategiespiel, wo ich eben versuchen muss, möglichst gut meine Ressourcen einzusetzen, über das Deduktionsspiel, wo ich mir eben was erschließen muss. Also es gibt eine wahnsinnige Bandbreite. Und das sieht man vielleicht auch daran. Im Gegensatz zum Buchbereich ist es natürlich lächerlich, aber für den Spielebereich, das verblüfft dann doch viele, dass vier bis fünfhundert Spiele im Jahr erscheinen.
Neue Spiele?
Neue Brettspiele. Und das kann natürlich keiner mehr spielen. Und vor ein paar Jahren war es eben so gut wie möglich, auch den aktuellen Jahrgang durchzuzocken.
Was heißt denn das? Das kann keiner mehr spielen? Also es kann nicht einer alle spielen?
Ja, genau. Das war früher aber so. Also man konnte sich einen guten Überblick über den Jahrgang verschaffen, als ich angefangen habe. Also mein erstes Brettspiel, bzw. das war ein Kartenspiel, entwickelt und veröffentlicht habe ich 1997.
Also Kartenspiele, können wir gleich noch hinzufügen, fallen bei dir also sozusagen auch unter Brettspiele?
Ja, im erweiterten Sinne eben, weil es keinen vernünftigen Begriff dafür gibt, der wirklich alles umfasst. Es gegenüber anderen Spielen wie Sport oder Computerspielen eben abgrenzt.
Warum sagt man nicht Tischspiele? Findest du nicht meistens auf dem Tisch statt? Oder um einen Tisch herum?
Doch, der Tisch ist oft ein zentrales Element. Aber du wirst immer Ausnahmen finden, egal worum es geht.
Mhm, ja stimmt.
Du hast halt nicht dieses eine Medium, wo es stattfindet, wie das...
Na, ich grübe gerade, ob es nicht vielleicht doch irgendwie so einen Begriff gibt, mit dem man es einfangen kann.
Brauchen wir noch, also die Wikipedia kennt auch noch keinen.
Aber es gibt da einen Artikel Brettspiele.
Es gibt einen Artikel Brettspiele, es gibt einen Artikel Autorenspiele. Autorenspiele, wie gesagt, liegen halt ein bisschen analog zum Autorenfilm den Schwerpunkt auf den Entwickler des Spiels. Ja, genau. Bloß bei einem Film sind natürlich meistens mehr Leute beteiligt als bei einem Brettspiel. Das ist das Schöne dran. Das Brettspiel kannst du erstmal im kleinen Kämmerlein erfinden. Und was man investieren muss, ist zunächst sehr, sehr gering. Das heißt also, do it yourself. Du brauchst eigentlich nichts als eine Dusche, wo du drunter stehen kannst und drüber nachdenken.
Das ist wie beim Programmieren eigentlich ein bisschen.
Also Duschen ist eine sehr gute Methode, um Brettspiele zu erfinden. Der öffentliche Nahverkehr ist alles wesentlich schwieriger geworden durch die mobilen Geräte, die einen ablenken. Früher hatte man so viel tote Zeit, das war unglaublich schön, die damit zu verbringen, über ein Spiel nachzudenken.
Das stimmt. Scheiß iPhone. Das zählt einfach dem Programmieren und vom Spielerfinden ab. Was schätzt du denn so persönlich an einem Spiel? Vielleicht kannst du ja auch mal so ein paar Games nennen, die jetzt nicht nur so erfolgreich waren, sondern die jetzt bei dir so besonders verfangen haben. Weil irgendwas muss es ja gegeben haben, was du jetzt auch besonders gemocht hast. Weil sonst, unterstelle ich mal, hättest du dich diesem Genre ja nie genährt. Oder war das jetzt einfach nur der Frust, dass hier alles scheiße und doof ist?
Ja, es war so eine Mischung. Also ich habe so etwas wie Risiko sehr gerne gespielt.
Also Risiko ist dieses Weltkarte-Armeen, relativ brutal eigentlich so. Wir übernehmen den Kontinent, lalala.
Und Australien ist ganz super als Kontinent, weil das so abgeschieden gelegen ist. Da kann man nicht so leicht angreifen und so weiter. Aber irgendwie dachte ich immer, dass irgendwas stimmt doch da noch nicht. Und ich konnte mir auch nicht vorstellen, dass es dann doch vielleicht schon Spiele gibt, wo es stimmt. Also habe ich angefangen, da selber dran rumzubasteln.
Was hat dich denn gestört? Also was hat denn nicht gestimmt?
Die waren so unausgewogen. Also Monopoly zum Beispiel ist unglaublich zäh irgendwann. Ich meine, da geht es ja darum, dass du die anderen in Ruinen fährst. Das heißt, irgendwann kriegst du halt da am Boden und der andere hat das ganze Geld und hat seinen Spaß an dem Spiel dadurch, dass er dir zuschauen kann, wie du eben pleite gehst. Die waren oft auch mir zu Glücks bestimmt. Ich wollte mehr Entscheidungen treffen, die sich auch irgendwie auswirken.
Also Glück, so ereigtes Karten.
Genau, der Prototyp des Spiels damals war Würfeln, Laufen mit einer Spielfigur und ein eigenes Ausführen. Das Witzige ist, ich habe mein erstes Spiel, wo überhaupt Würfel vorkommen, vor letztes Jahr gemacht. In allen anderen Spielen gibt es überhaupt keine Würfel. Das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen, wenn man denkt, wenn man so an Brettspiele denkt. Die Spiele haben sich sehr, sehr entwickelt, und zwar genau in die Richtung, die mich interessiert. Nämlich...
Weg mit dem Zufall.
Ja, wenn man den gut einsetzt, ist der Zufall schon auch wichtig.
Also es ist nicht durch den Zufall dominiert.
Genau, du hast einfach eine kleine Welt, die du da aus dieser Schachtel rausholst, in der du dich bewegen kannst, nach bestimmten Regeln. Und die Anforderung an ein gutes Spiel ist, die Regeln müssen möglichst einfach sein, aber die Welt trotzdem sehr vielfältig. Wenn man jetzt mal ein bisschen näher argumentieren will an den Hörern deines Podcasts, dann nehmen wir mal Twitter als Beispiel. Twitter wäre so eine Welt. Da hast du drei, vier Regeln, was du machen kannst, aber was du dann im Endeffekt damit machst, das ist halt unglaublich groß. Und so funktioniert auch ein gutes Brettspiel. Du legst eigentlich wenig fest, was die Spieler machen müssen, sondern du bietest ihnen nur einen Handlungsrahmen, der schöne Effekte hat.
Ich würde jetzt mal gar nicht unterstellen, dass die Leute, die das jetzt hier hören und nicht... Dass die Twitter kennen. Ja, einmal das so, aber das Spiele. Ich meine, sagen wir mal jetzt auch in der Computer geprägt, in der Gekke, Jugendkultur. Da brauche ich nur meine eigene Geschichte zurückzublicken. Spielen ja auch Rollenspiele eine große Rolle, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Und für die gilt ja genau das, was du auch gesagt hast. Man hat da eine Welt, die hat eben einen bestimmten Satz an Regeln, der, gerade wenn er sehr einfach gehalten ist, sehr erfolgreich ist. Also für mich ist es so in unserer Stellung, dass irgendwie Rollenspiele besonders dann gut greifen, wenn das Regelwerk überschaubar ist und sich daraus dann eben genug übergibt. Das leite ich jetzt einfach davon ab, dass ich selber mal, wir haben selber irgendwie mal unsere Regelwerke da ausgebaut und wir wurden dann immer komplizierter, bis es dann irgendwann alles so unspielbar war, dass der einzige Nebeneffekt von dem ganzen Regelschreiben war, dass ich mal ordentlich Deutsch gelernt habe, also in der Schrift. Aber trotzdem, das ist ja eigentlich dasselbe Faszinosum an der Stelle.
Ja und Brettspiele sind da eben an der Stelle, was jetzt zum Beispiel die Einfachheit der Regeln angeht. Die sind vielleicht jetzt noch da, wo die Computerspiele ganz am Anfang waren. Und zwar im positiven Sinne. Das heißt, du hast ganz begrenzte Ressourcen und musst damit möglichst viel rausholen. Du hast keine Recheneinheit da drin, die dir komplizierte Dinge abnehmen kann. Das heißt, die Regeln müssen so gestaltet sein, dass sie einfach genug sind, dass sie verstanden werden von den Spielern. Das heißt, der Schwerpunkt liegt natürlich dann auch auf der Originalität, darauf wirklich ein System zu schaffen, was an sich schon toll ist. Da geht es nicht um die Showwerte. Ein Spiel verkauft sich nicht, bloß weil die Grafik toll ist. Das wird nicht funktionieren, ein Brettspiel. Das heißt, diese Reduktion und die Einschränkung, die du hast als Spieleautor, wirkt sich auf die Spiele sehr positiv aus. Weil du wirklich alles so weit runterbrechen musst, wie es geht.
Was ist denn bei dem, was dir jetzt gefallen hat oder nicht gefallen hat, welche Art von Kick hast du denn sozusagen erwartet? Oder welcher Kick hat dich eingesetzt, sodass du dann dazu übergegangen bist, selber Spiele entwickeln zu wollen? Was ist der Reiz während des Spiels, in dem du dich ausgesetzt sehen möchtest? Was ist der Reiz, den du andere Leute ausgesetzt sehen möchtest, wenn sie sich damit beschäftigen?
Also viele Spiele waren sehr reizvoll am Anfang des Spiels und liefen dann auseinander, weil einer der Spieler einfach zu mächtig geworden ist. Und wenn du einen übermächtigen Spieler im Spiel hast, dann macht es nicht mehr so viel Spaß. Du hast das Gefühl, du kannst einfach nichts mehr machen.
Das ist ja wahrscheinlich auch, warum die anderen so viel mit dem Würfeln und dem Zufall gearbeitet haben, weil es dann...
Um es irgendwie auszugleichen.
Ja, ich nehme jedem immer wieder die Möglichkeit zu geben, reinzukommen oder auch nicht.
Also im Grunde kann man das gut vergleichen mit der Marktwirtschaft. Ist auch ein Spielsystem. Macht am Anfang viel Spaß, wenn das Einkommen relativ gleich verteilt ist. Mit der Dauer aber häufen sich die Effekte, dass das Einkommen so unterschiedlich verteilt ist, dass einzelne Teilnehmer an dem Spiel einfach keinen Spaß mehr haben und keinen Bock mehr haben. Bei der Marktwirtschaft kann man dann sagen, okay, ihr müsst es halt jetzt weiter spielen. Bei einem Brettspiel sagen die halt, wir legen die Schachtel weg, ich nehme mir ein anderes Spiel. Was einen netten Effekt hatte, was die Entwicklung der Brettspiele anging, weil wir mussten tatsächlich schauen, Systeme zu finden, also auch Marktsysteme, die funktionieren und Spaß machen. Und auch noch begreiflich sind, also nicht mit 800 Regeln, wie das in Gesetzen so ist, sondern wirklich alles so runterbrechen, dass wir viel Effekt haben mit ganz wenig Einsatz sozusagen.
Und sehr viel Zufriedenheit bei allen Beteiligten.
Und sehr viel Zufriedenheit, weil bei 500 Spielen, da greift man sich natürlich nur die raus, die einem wirklich gefallen. Und das finde ich eigentlich auch einen sehr, sehr spannenden Aspekt an Brettspielen, dass wir sozusagen Feldforschung betreiben, was soziale Interaktion angeht, in Regelsystemen.
Also ich erinnere mich, es gab ein Spiel, was ich sehr gerne gespielt habe und was viele dieser Kriterien, die du gerade genannt hast, für mich auch erfüllt hat, das war Hase und Igel. Ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, wann das überhaupt rauskam.
Wann es rauskam, ich glaube, da gab es mehrere Ausgaben, das wurde auf jeden Fall 1979 zum Spiel des Jahres gewählt, zum allerersten Spiel des Jahres überhaupt. Und war auch eins, vielleicht sage ich jetzt dazu viel, aber war auch eins dieser ersten Spiele, die so in diese Richtung des Runden gingen. Also die wirklich dann funktioniert haben.
Ja, weil da gab es keinen Würfel.
Bis auf die Klassiker, da sowieso schon immer. Also ein Schach funktioniert auch.
Jaja, genau, richtig. Schach hat auch keinen Würfel. Das ist auch gut so, aber bei Hase und Igel war vieles von dem drin. Also alles wurde eigentlich von der eigenen Strategie dominiert. Man wusste, wenn man da gegenüber den anderen sich einen Vorteil erarbeitet hatte, dass das eigentlich von einem selbst abhing. Und das hatte wiederum auf mich einen extrem großen Reiz.
Genau, und da bewegen wir uns auf einem sehr schmalen Grad. Denn wir brauchen dieses Spannungsfeld, dass mir alle Möglichkeiten offen stehen in einem Spiel. Dass ich also sozusagen viel tun kann, dass es aber nicht auseinanderläuft, also divergiert, sondern dass das Spiel fokussiert bleibt, dass die Spieler untereinander nicht zu sehr sich trennen, was die Möglichkeiten angeht. Also dass die Spannung sozusagen von Anfang bis Ende gehalten wird im Spiel. Sodass ich selbst wenn ich hinten liege, am Ende noch das Gefühl habe, es hat irgendeinen Sinn hier weiter zu machen. Sonst gebe ich ja auf. Dass die Glücksfaktoren da sind, aber nicht zu übermächtig sind. Also dass ich das Gefühl habe, ich habe mein Schicksal in der Hand, aber vielleicht ist mir ja auch das Glück heult und gibt mir noch mal den entscheidenden Push. Also es ist wirklich gar nicht so einfach, ein Spiel so zu designen, dass die Leute sich frei fühlen. Weil sie begeben sich freiwillig in ein Regelsystem von willkürlichen Regeln, die sie akzeptieren müssen, was erstmal einengt. Aber dieses Regelsystem muss ihnen eigentlich die Freiheit geben, sich zu entfalten. Und das ist der Grund, warum ich denke, dass Brettspiele eigentlich auch eine große Bedeutung haben gesellschaftlich, weil sie viele Fragen tangieren, die wichtig sind. Wie gestalten wir eben unsere Gesetze, dass die Leute sich frei fühlen, dass sie sie akzeptieren freiwillig. Und dass trotzdem ein System herauskommt, was funktioniert. Denn Wettbewerb ist in Spielen unglaublich wichtig. Und das heißt also, dass ich besser sein kann als du. Aber trotzdem wird der Verlierer nicht ausgeschlossen.
Ja, und es muss ja auch so ein ausgleichendes Moment geben. Ich meine, wenn man jetzt gerade in so einem Strategiespiel ist, was mich dann immer frustriert, ist natürlich, wenn man mit Leuten zusammenspielt, die das dann einfach ganz toll können, weil sie einfach die kombinatorische Gaber haben, die eben meine Fähigkeiten in dem Moment übersteigt, dann tendiert man ja auch schnell dazu zu sagen, bist mir mal wieder zu klug, ich gehe lieber mit den doofen Fußballspielen. Es gibt auch diesen Effekt, dass solche Spiele ja auch so einen Ausgleich schaffen. Ich meine, an der Stelle ist der Würfel oder was weiß ich, die Ereigniskarte natürlich auch so ein ausgleichendes Moment. Dass sozusagen auch dieses, selbst wenn man eigentlich im Vorteil ist, kann man eben auch immer noch scheitern.
Ja, also es gibt viele Elemente, die da ganz bewusst reingetragen werden, die eben solchen Ausgleich ermöglichen. Es gibt aber eine Bandbreite von Spielen. Es gibt natürlich auch Spiele, die du hinstellen kannst, die kann dann jemand, der nicht viel spielt, einfach nicht spielen. Mit jemandem, der viel spielt. Aber dafür gibt es eben die Bandbreite. Und die wirklich erfolgreichen Sachen, wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel Siedler von Katarn nimmt oder Carcassonne, die haben eben beide Elemente drin. Carcassonne hat den Würfel drin. Entschuldigung, Siedler von Katarn hat den Würfel drin. Und Carcassonne hat eben den Zufall des Plättchenziehens. Kannst du mal ein bisschen erklären, was es ist?
Genau, eigentlich wollte ich gerade fragen, dass man ein paar Beispiele nennst für Spiele, wo diese Elemente, die du beschreibst, die man jetzt sozusagen ausgewogen entwickeln sollte. Wo das auch gut umgesetzt ist, sind das Beispiele dafür?
Das sind gute Beispiele dafür.
Erklär doch mal, was Siedler von Katarn sind.
Die Siedler von Katarn sind wahrscheinlich von den modernen Spielen das, was jeder kennt.
Ich kenne es nicht.
Nein, du kennst es nicht? Gut. Die Siedler von Katarn, du besiedelst eine Insel, du tauscht Rohstoffe. Also erstmal kannst du nicht...
Was hat man? Man hat so ein Brett im Tisch?
Man hat ein flexibles Brett. Das war damals eine große Neuerung in dem normalen Brettspielbereich, dass das Brett jedes Mal anders ist. Du setzt es aus so Hexfeldern zusammen.
Also hexagonal.
Jedes Hexfeld hat einen Rohstoff. Zum Beispiel ein Wald gibt Holz und eine Erzmine gibt Erz. Also ein Gebirge gibt Erz. Und du kannst dort eben Siedlungen bauen und Städte bauen und bekommst über den Würfel gesteuert Rohstoffe, da wo du dran bist. Wenn du am Wald stehst, kriegst du Holz. Dann gibt es ein Element, dass man mit den anderen Mitspielern tauschen kann. Und im Nachhinein benutzt du dann diese Rohstoffe dafür.
Was meinst du, es gibt ein Element?
Also es gibt so eine Phase. Man kann tauschen. Im Spiel gibt es, also jeder Spielzug besteht aus Phasen. Ich würfel erst, dann bekomme ich Rohstoffe oder alle bekommen Rohstoffe. Dann kommt die Handelsphase. Das heißt, ich kann mit den anderen tauschen. Und als letztes kommt die Bauphase. Bei der Bauphase kann ich Straßen bauen, Siedlungen und Städte. Um mit den Rohstoffen kannst du die bauen, um eben wieder mehr Rohstoffe zu kriegen. Und so entsteht eben so eine Stadt. Und dieses Würfeln, da gibt es einen besonderen Mechanismus. Wenn ich eine sieben würfle, dann kommt der Räuber und nimmt den anderen Karten weg. Dann kann ich den irgendwo hinsetzen. Und die anderen verlieren Karten. Und das ist eben zum Beispiel so ein Zufallselement, was ausgleichend wirkt, weil man dann eben gezielt gegen den Führenden spielt und sagt, okay, ich stelle den Räuber zu dir, dann kriegst du da keine Rohstoffe mehr. Das habe ich jetzt nicht erklärt. Da, wo der Räuber steht, da gibt es keine Rohstoffe, weil der nimmt die für sich. Und bei Carcassonne bauen wir so eine Stadt auf, aus Plättchen. Und können unsere Figuren setzen. Die können dann ein Bauer sein und die Wiese bewirtschaften. Oder in der Stadt die Stadt bewirtschaften. Oder eine Straße, dort Zoll verlangen. Und dafür gibt es immer Punkte. Wenn ich da eine schöne Stadt gebaut habe, dann kriegt der, der in der Stadt steht, eben Punkte dafür. Und da ist das Ausgleichenelement der Kartenstapel. Ich weiß nicht, welche Karten kommen. Und da kann ich eben Glück haben oder nicht Glück haben. Oh, ich kann jetzt meine Stadt fertig bauen. Oder, oh, das ist jetzt ein Plättchen, was ich nicht so gut benötige. Nicht so sehr benötige.
Die waren auch recht erfolgreich, die beiden.
Die waren sehr erfolgreich, also millionenfach verkauft. Auch ins Ausland. Das erscheint dann als Lizenz in anderen Ländern. Man muss aber dazu sagen, Deutschland ist der größte Brettspielmarkt weltweit momentan.
In Deutschland wird so viel verkauft, gemacht, gespielt. Bitte? Was heißt größer Markt? Es wird am meisten gekauft. Man könnte auch sagen, es wird am meisten gespielt.
Warum? Das ist eine schöne Frage. Wird da am meisten gespielt, wo am meisten gekauft wird? Spiele sind schon Geschenkartikel meistens. Viele werden nicht gespielt. Aber ich denke schon, dass es in Deutschland dann auch am meisten gespielt wird. Das ist eine gute Frage. Vielleicht hat es mit der Entwicklung des Spiels des Jahres zu tun. Wir hatten seit 1979 diesen Preis Spiel des Jahres. Das ist wie der Oscar für Spiele. Jedes Jahr bekommt ein Spiel diesen Preis verliehen. Die Leute haben das dann als Qualitätssiegel anerkannt und eben dieses Spiel gekauft. Das Spiel des Jahres verkauft sich etwa 20-mal so viel wie ein normales Spiel.
Wer entscheidet darüber?
Das sind immer so ein Dutzend Journalisten, die über Spiele schreiben. Das ist die Voraussetzung. Die bekommen jetzt persönlich kein Geld dafür, sondern auf diesen Preis Spiel des Jahres wird eine Lizenz gezahlt. Der Verlag bezahlt eine Lizenz an die Jury, damit er dieses Signet auf die Schachtel drucken darf.
Daraus finanziert sich dann die Preisvergabe?
Genau. Das hat sich relativ schnell etabliert. Wenn du ein Spiel im Jahr kaufst, dann kaufst du meistens das Spiel des Jahres. Auch wenn es natürlich nicht immer das beste Spiel ist. Was ist das Beste?
Hast du eine Vermutung, warum in Deutschland das Thema so groß ist? Vielleicht kannst du das selber festmachen.
Ich bin in einer Zeit aufgewachsen, wo es zum guten Ton gehörte, mit den Kindern Brettspiele zu spielen. Welche Zeit ist das? Ich bin 1977 geboren. Da war das einfach so.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das mit den 68ern zu tun hat. Ich bin zehn Jahre älter. Das war schon üblich.
Man machte das einfach so, wie man Kindern Bücher vorliest.
Dieses Spiel des Jahres hat schnell den Weg in die Öffentlichkeit gefunden.
Es gehört einfach dazu, wenn ich eine Liste habe, Baby-Windeln, dann in den Kindergarten schicken, Spiele mit ihm spielen. Aber warum?
Warum nicht irgendwas anderes? Was machen die anderen Länder? Was ist an unserem Kulturraum? Ist es dieses Um-den-Tisch-herum-Sitzen und im Spiel vereint, Familie feiern? Oder ist es die Herausforderung, ist es der Hang zur Strategie? Oder ist es die Liebe zu regeln? Kann es das sein, dass wir gesetzes- und regelverliebt sind, dass dieses spielerische Mit-Gesetzen-Spielen hier auch so gut Fuß fasst? Die Orkungsliebe?
Es ist ganz komisch, aber wenn ich mich so an die Werbung in den 80er Jahren erinnere, wenn da die Mutter mit ihren Kindern sich an den Tisch gesetzt hat und dem Vater dann Essen gebracht hat und dann noch ihr Waschmittel auf den Tisch gestellt hat und ihre Hände in irgendwas gebadet, da passt einfach ein Brettspiel Ich finde das ist ein Brettspiel, wie die Faust aufs Auge dazu findet. Diese Situation, dieses Familien- und jetzt noch ein heiteres Brettspiel. Also das ist, ich finde das ist schon sehr deutsch.
Ja, aber es klingt ja so ein bisschen abfällig. Ich meine, das muss ja auch irgendeinen positiven Effekt haben. Leute müssen ja irgendwas auch mögen, wenn sie das tun. Das ist ja nicht nur wegen der Werbung oder weil alle anderes machen.
Ich glaube, es gibt viele Eltern, die das als Pflicht empfunden haben damals. Und nicht weil ihnen das besonders Spaß gemacht hat, sondern es gehörte zur Erziehung. Den Spaß haben eigentlich die Studenten am Brettspiel.
Gibt es da noch andere Länder, wo es zumindest so halbwegs populär ist?
Also durch das Internet lustigerweise hat eine große Popularisierungswelle begonnen. Also in Holland ist das Brettspiel sehr populär geworden und in Amerika. Amerika merkt man es ganz, ganz doll, weil da die Verkaufszahlen hochgegangen sind. Da gab es genug Spieler, die Brettspiele spielen wollten. Die war nur überall verstreut in Amerika und Amerika ist groß. Das heißt, die Masse ist da jetzt auch sehr groß, weil die halt viel mehr Einwohner haben. Aber die konnten sich nicht austauschen. Und da ist ein interessanter Effekt entstanden, als diese Qualität der Brettspiele in Deutschland sich verbessert hat. Das war so um diese Sieler-Zeit rum, als Sieler 95 rausgekommen ist. Also ein bisschen vorher hat das schon angefangen. Da gab es einen findigen Verleger in Amerika. Der hat gesagt, okay, ich fahre jetzt nach Deutschland und hole mir die Lizenzen und publiziere die Spiele in Amerika. Und da hat er sich die ganzen Perlen rausgepickt, die es in Deutschland gab, und hat die besten Sachen in Amerika veröffentlicht. Rio Grande ist das gewesen. Und das ist natürlich toll, wenn du das Feinste vom Feinsten kriegst. Das ist ja ein bisschen so wie hier die amerikanischen Serien. In Amerika gibt es ja viel mehr Serien. Der ganze Schrott kommt ja hier gar nicht an, sondern die tollsten Sachen. Und so ging es andersrum. Und über das Internet hat sich das dann halt drum gesprochen, sodass in der amerikanischen Brettspielszene der Begriff German Games als Markenqualität aus Deutschland irgendwann sich eingebürgert hat.
So wie Autos.
Und da ist ganz interessant, dass jedes Land doch einen anderen Blick auf Spiele hat. Also die Amis haben auch, die German Games gelten als sehr analytisch. Also da geht es eher um den Mechanismus als ums Thema. Oft wird dann so ein Thema drauf geklatscht. Wir spielen jetzt in Indien, hat aber mit Indien gar nichts zu tun. Ob ich jetzt da meine Spielfigur zwei Felder nach rechts bewege, was ist daran in Indien? Das interessiert da meistens nicht. Die Amerikaner kamen eher von diesen Ereignisorientierten. Also eben auch diese Ereigniskarten und so.
Da gibt es da einen World Cup, Mensch, alle, die sich nicht hören.
Ich weiß nicht. Da gibt es halt auch so Spiele wie Munchkin, wo du dann in so ein Dungeon gehst und Monster abschlachtest. Also es ist so eine Satire auf diese Monster-D&D-Spiele. Da geht es dann mehr um diesen Fun. Und die Franzosen spielen auch noch mal ein bisschen anders. Die haben dann gerne auch mal ein bisschen Spaß und Bewegung drin. Die Deutschen spielen, glaube ich, am ernstesten.
Echt, die Franzosen müssen hampeln?
Ja, oder auch diese kommunikativen Spiele kommen da sehr gut an.
Was würdest du als ein kommunikatives Spiel bezeichnen? Wo man sich so fragen muss?
Was bezeichnen muss zum Beispiel, oder was erraten, was der andere macht? Und am nettesten ist eigentlich Italien. Da sage ich immer, da gibt es mehr Spieleentwickler als Spieler. Es gibt unglaublich viele Italiener, die Spiele entwickeln. Und interessante Spiele auch entwickeln, aber wenig Abnahme. Gerade in die südlichen Länder oder da, wo es warm ist, wird halt weniger Brett gespielt, weil man sich eher draußen aufhält.
Also das Brettspiel ist schon, kann man sagen, ein deutsches Phänomen. Ist es jetzt nur Deutschland oder gilt das genauso für Österreich?
Für Österreich gilt das auch noch sehr. Die haben eine relativ aktive Spielesszene. Schweiz ist halt dreigeteilt durch die Sprache.
Klar.
Da ist es nicht mehr ganz so viel. Aber vor zehn Jahren hätte ich das sofort unterstrichen. Das ist ein deutsches Phänomen. Es hat sich viel getan. Es gibt mittlerweile sehr viele ausländische Publisher, also Verlage, dadurch, dass sich die Produktionstechnik weiterentwickelt hat. Die sehr klein sind, aber eine unglaubliche Menge produzieren. Wir haben mittlerweile den großen Vorteil, dass die Produktion ausgelagert werden konnte. Es gibt ein, zwei Anbieter, da kannst du hingehen und sagen, ich will dieses Spiel produzieren. Ich brauche das und das und das Material. Also meistens Standardmaterial. Standardmaterial sind Holzfiguren und Spielkarten und Stanzbögen, also so Pappteile. Und da kannst du hingehen und sagen, produzieren wir das in der Auflage und dann kriegst du das einfach fertig geliefert.
Weil die einfach entsprechende Maschinen haben, die man nicht koalieren kann.
Genau, die sind spezialisiert, sozusagen outgesourct. Also die wenigsten Verlage produzieren selber mittlerweile. Aber das kannst auch du machen, wenn du Lust hast und das Geld dafür hast.
Auch so ein einzelner Auflagen, ist das dann irgendwie auch schon bezahlbar?
Wie viel?
Na, wenn man jetzt so nur wenige Auflagen macht.
Also so ab 3000 Stück.
3000? Das ist schon eine Menge, ne?
So ab 3000 Stück.
Aber so jetzt so als Weihnachtsgeschenk für den erweiterten Familienkreis?
Das lohnt sich so nicht, dann lieber basteln.
Okay. Oder man kennt jemand, der eine Laser-Karte hat, ne?
Ja.
Das sind Hacker-Spaces.
So ein Make-Up-Bot ist da sicherlich auch ganz cool.
Ja, damit könnte man sich die Spielsteine bauen und dann mit dem Laser-Cutter macht man sich dann so die Brettelemente. Das verärgert nochmal.
Also wir haben ja auch so einen scherzhaft so einen kleinen Kreis gebildet unter den Spiele-Entwicklern, der heißt die Büroartikel-Fetischisten. Weil wir irgendwann festgestellt haben, wir gehen in einen Büroartikel-Laden rein und es ist das Himmelreich. Und da gibt es dann eine Eckenstanze, wo man dann die Karten abrunden kann mit und irgendwelche, was weiß ich, Papierschneideräte und alles mögliche. Also es ist wirklich herrlich und ich träume ja immer noch davon, ich setze mich an einen Computer und sage, bitte druck mir das so aus, schneid mir das so aus, bekleet mir das so. Weil persönlich, ich hasse das Basteln beim Brettspielen und es ist halt nötig. Du musst das tun.
Warum muss man das tun? Gut kommt der aufs Spiel an, ne?
Du musst ja einen echten Prototypen schaffen, den man dann auch spielen kann. Weil der fällt nicht vom Himmel.
Das heißt, du bist mehr so der Mann fürs Regelwerk, aber...
Ich bin mehr der Mann fürs Regeln, fürs Bauen nicht. Bei der Illustration bin ich dann wieder dabei. Also ich illustriere auch schon lange Brettspiele. Aber ja, nicht das Basteln, das finde ich anscheinend.
Ist das für dich eigentlich ein Beruf oder Hobby oder wo ist das angesiedelt?
Also es war für mich immer Beruf, aber da ich auch immer mehrere Berufe hatte, schon allein Illustration und Brettspiele, läuft es nicht als einziges bei mir. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall ein Beruf. Und wenn man sich mehr damit beschäftigen würde, also das ist halt schwierig. Ich würde es gerne, aber ich habe meistens nicht die Zeit dafür, weil du brauchst eben diese Anfangsinvestition erst mal machen können, das heißt genug Geld haben, dass du erst mal entwickeln kannst. Weil das Geld kommt natürlich erst dann, wenn das Spiel auf dem Markt ist. Das heißt, man müsste mal ein Jahr vor finanzieren können, um das hauptberuflich machen zu können. Deswegen machen das halt die meisten Leute, die es hauptberuflich machen, haben dann halt ein Spiel des Jahres gekriegt oder so und konnten sich dann dadurch selbstständig machen.
Also gekriegt haben sie sich verdient sozusagen, indem sie dann auch was tolles geschaffen haben. Waren denn die Spiele des Jahres bisher alle gut?
Nein, natürlich nicht. Das ist wie bei den Oscars, das eine Jahr ist gut und das nächste Jahr ist halt dann ein Griff in den Ofen, aber ein Schuss in den Ofen oder auch mal ins Klo. Das wollte ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Hier darf man alles sagen.
Aber... Aber durchschnittlich ist die Qualität natürlich überdurchschnittlich, wenn das jetzt Sinn macht, dieser Satz. Aber macht er, wenn man drüber nachdenkt.
Ich glaube, er wurde verstanden.
Also das durchschnittliche Spiel des Jahres ist besser als das durchschnittliche Spiel.
Was hat er denn sonst noch? Ich meine, bleiben wir noch mal ein bisschen bei Beispielen, um dann auch mal so ein bisschen diese Bandbreite sichtbar werden zu lassen. Also Siedler, da ist ja auch so dieses, was ich jetzt vor allem mitgenommen habe, so dieses Handelselement, das sind ja auch so, kommen wir sicherlich auch gleich noch zu, das ist ja auch so ein Element, was ja in Computerspielen dann auch sehr stark aufgenommen worden ist. Gab es nicht sogar genau von diesem Siedler dann auch eine digitale, also hat das unmittelbar was damit zu tun?
Das war eine nette Geschichte, weil die kamen fast gleichzeitig raus. Aber die Siedler auf dem Computer waren ein bisschen vorher. Und da gab es auch noch einen Namensstreit. Und deswegen heißen die Siedler auch die Siedler von Katarn.
Ah, verstehe.
Um das auseinanderzuhalten. Und dann später, als dann eine Computerversion von den Siedlern kam, mussten die das dann die erste Insel nennen. Katarn, die erste Insel, damit Siedler nicht in Konflikt gerät mit den Siedlern. Die haben eigentlich nichts miteinander zu tun. Es gibt auch ein sehr bekanntes Brettspiel Civilization. Das hat auch nichts zu tun mit dem Civilization. Und mittlerweile gibt es auch noch ein Civilization-Brettspiel vom Computerspiel. Also sehr verwirrend.
Aber trotzdem, das passt ganz gut zusammen eigentlich, oder? Ich meine, vielleicht adressiert das ja sogar dieselbe Art von Menschen.
Also dieses Siedler von Katarn war sozusagen diese komplexe Welt, wenn ich jetzt so eine Aufbau-Simulation nehme, einfach eingedampft in ein Spiel. Alles möglichst einfach, aber dafür jedes Element drin. Ressourcenverwaltung, Verhandeln, leichte kriegerische Aspekte. Das ist auch ein interessanter Punkt in der Brettspiel-Szene, wie damit umgegangen wird. Also das war alles drin, auch ein bisschen Glück noch dabei. Ja, genau, da wollte ich jetzt darauf eingehen, auf diese kriegerischen Aspekte. Dadurch, dass es aus Deutschland kommt, hauptsächlich momentan, gibt es diese, eine gewisse Ethik. So eine, Ravensburger hat die eigentlich geprägt. Wir machen keine kriegerischen Spiele. Und bei den deutschen Verlagen ist das tatsächlich eine ganz arge Hemmschwelle. Also das, was im Computerspielbereich möglich wäre, wäre in den Brettspielen kaum zu finden. Es gibt auch ganz wenig satirische Sachen oder so. Die gibt es auch, die kommen dann aber eher bei kleinen Verlagen raus. Oder Geschmackloses, das findet man dann bei USA-Brettspielen. Also es gibt da so eine Schere im Kopf, was man machen darf und was man nicht machen darf. Aber wenn die deutschen Brettspiele ein Podcast wären, dann würden sie mit clean gelabelt und nicht mit explicit.
Verstehe, dann würde man dann keinen Griff ins Klo machen.
Und dann kommen wir zu einem interessanten Punkt, bei den Computerspielen. Die Politik regt sich immer über die Computerspiele auf. Aber wir haben die Brettspielszene in Deutschland, die die größte weltweit ist, das Leuchtfeuer. Die springen aber nicht drauf auf und sagen, guck mal, wir haben hier das Vorzeigeprodukt. Das kannst du jedem Kind hinlegen, ohne dass es sozial verkommt. Brettspiele spielen politisch keine Rolle.
Naja, vielleicht genau wegen dieser Selbstzensur da im Kopf.
Vielleicht wegen der Selbstzensur. Aus einem zweiten Aspekt raus, sind sie Kultur oder sind sie Commerz? Es gibt nämlich zwei Sachen, die in Deutschland wichtig sind. Die Kulturgüter, das sind Bücher und Theater und Oper. Und die Sachen, die kommerziell erfolgreich sind. Also Computerspiele mittlerweile, war ja auch nicht immer so. Und Film und Musikindustrie. Und die Brettspiele erfüllen beide Kriterien nicht und fallen deswegen total runter. Also Brettspiele gibt es eigentlich nicht, obwohl es sie gibt. Es interessiert sich aber keiner dafür. Es ist Kultur. Und da kommt eine nächste Konsequenz. Und jetzt mache ich einen ganz weiten Bogen, wohin wir vielleicht nicht hinkommen wollten. Da habe ich dann immer Angst vor der Kultur-Flatrate. Weil, weißt du, dann zahlen die Bürger ein eben für ihre Kultur und dürfen sich dann was rausnehmen aus dem Pool. Aber es gibt dann eine Kommission, die bestimmt was Kultur ist. Und die Brettspiele sind da nicht dabei, weil die interessieren keinen. Die gibt es nicht. Also das gleiche Problem haben wir mit dem Urheberrecht auch, was Brettspiele angeht. Das wird nicht explizit erwähnt. Im Grunde kann man aber schützen, ist unbekannt. Und vielleicht kann man es auch gar nicht.
Lass uns auf diesen Pfad vielleicht nachher noch mal kommen. Aber ausgegangen sind wir jetzt ein bisschen, noch von meinem Wunsch, noch mal so ein paar Spiele, noch mal so ein bisschen in ihrem in ihrem Wesen so zu machen. Und kriegerische Elemente. Ich meine, was nicht Risiko kommt jetzt ja nicht aus Deutschland, oder?
Ja, bei Risiko gibt es eine sehr, sehr schöne Geschichte. Risiko ging es am Anfang so, sie müssen folgende Armeen vernichten. Es gibt so Auftragskarten bei Risiko am Anfang. Vernichten sie die roten Armeen. Und dann gab es eine Diskussion, ja, vielleicht sollten wir Risiko auf den Index setzen.
In Deutschland?
In Deutschland.
Wo kam das jetzt her, aus den USA?
Das kommt aus den USA. Beziehungsweise der Autor ist Francois Lamouris. Das könnte auch ein Franzose gewesen sein. Also das bin ich mir nicht sicher. Aber der Verlag, ja. Gut. Und was haben die dann gemacht? Sie haben auf die Karten draufgeschrieben, befreien sie Nordeuropa. Nordeuropa ist jetzt falsch, aber befreien sie Asien und Südamerika.
Also auf einzelne Auftragskarten.
Ja genau. Anstatt greifen sie an oder vernichten sie.
Ah, verstehe.
Und dann war es okay.
Ein Befreiungskrieg.
Und dann war es okay. Und das ist so absurd und so heuchlerisch. Und das zieht sich halt bis heute durch in den Brettspielen.
Befreien sie den Kosovo.
Da ist es dann kein Kampf, sondern ein Konflikt. Und kein Krieg und sowas. Also völlig absurd. Und jeder weiß, worum es in Risiko geht. Da geht es ums Drauflagen und den anderen Fertigmachen. Also es nicht sagen dürfen, das war schon ganz interessant.
Vielleicht könnte man den Killerspielen ja dadurch auch irgendwie noch mal einen anderen Spin geben.
Ja, markieren sie ihren Gegner mit Farbe.
Und unterstreichen sie ihren Punkt durch einen gezielten Schuss.
Aber du wolltest gleich noch auf die Bandbreite hinaus?
Ja, wir haben viel über die Theorie, was ein Spiel ausmachen soll, was so die Dynamik ist, aber dabei noch relativ allgemein geblieben. Und ich finde es jetzt einfach mal auch ganz gut, das mal an so ein paar Spielen zu manifestieren. Risiko ist auf jeden Fall, hätte ich jetzt eh angesprochen, gerade weil da eben diese kriegerische Auseinandersetzung so eine Rolle spielt. Und jetzt wo du auch sagst, okay, Deutschland ist jetzt, also das ist jetzt hier mal wieder etwas, wo Deutschland eine Sonderrolle spielt. Da muss man sich natürlich immer wieder fragen, woran liegt das? Nicht wahr? Meine eine These war halt die Regelverliebtheit, aber das andere, was natürlich auch mal ist, ist dieses Kriegsecho. Vielleicht hat das ja auch mit reingespielt. Aber davon unabhängig, mich interessieren einfach noch so, was für Elemente es sozusagen jetzt in guten Beispielen von Brettspielen gibt, die jetzt einfach dem einfach einen gewissen Spin geben. Also wenn du jetzt mal so überlegst, welche Spiele du gerne gespielt hast oder die aus anderen Gründen populär waren, würde mich einfach interessieren, warum waren diese Spiele jetzt. Also was war sozusagen das entscheidende Element oder ein oder mehrere Elemente, die jetzt so einen Thrill erzeugt haben, dass man da auch dran bleibt, dass man das gerne spielt oder wo man auch gemerkt hat, dass zieht größere Gruppen zusammen, da findet man leichter Mitspieler. Gibt es da noch Beispiele?
Vor zwei Jahren, Spiel des Jahres, war Dominion. Da war halt toll der Kartenmechanismus. Also du baust dir sozusagen einen Kartenstapel auf und der bestimmt dann deine Fähigkeiten, die du im Spiel hast. Das Schöne an dem Spiel war, dass es dadurch unglaublich flexibel wurde. Also du, in einem traditionellen Spiel hast du einfach verschiedene Möglichkeiten, was du tun kannst und du machst es dann immer weiter und immer weiter. Und da bildest du dir sozusagen einen persönlichen Charakter aus. Ich kann eben, das ist auch zufällig oder was? Nee, nicht zufällig. Du hast Karten in der Mitte liegen, aus denen du auswählen kannst und du kaufst die.
Na ja, okay. Das heißt, du hast einen begrenzten Pool, mit dem du kaufen kannst und dann musst du da deine Kompromisse eingehen, ob du dir mehr diese oder jede Eigenschaft erhaust.
Und du bildest dir eben, man sagt dazu Deck, also einen Kartenstapel, ich bilde mir einen Deck und kann diese Eigenschaften immer wieder benutzen. Und da gab es halt einen besonders pfiffigen Mechanismus, dass ich eben Siegpunkte-Karten auf meine Kartenhand in dieses Deck mir kaufen musste, die mich aber während des Spiels blockieren. Also Siegpunkte sind das, was am Ende des Spiels zählt. So, wenn ich jetzt eine Siegpunkte-Karte am Anfang des Spiels kaufe, dann kommt die immer wieder auf meine Hand. Ich kann aber mit der keine Aktion ausführen. Ich kann nur mit allen anderen Karten, die ich kaufe, Aktionen ausführen. Das heißt, die blockiert mich.
Das heißt, umso mehr Erfolg du hast, umso mehr wirst du gebremst.
Ja, da kommen wir auch wieder zu diesen Effekten, wie man so Regelsysteme schafft, die eben negative Rückkupplung drin haben. Und das war halt sehr pfiffig, weil du den richtigen Zeitpunkt kriegen musst. Also so Timing-Spiele sind zum Beispiel auch sehr spannend, wo du dann vom Gefühl her wissen musst, ok, wann greife ich zu und wann baue ich noch meine Fähigkeiten auf. Und besonders gute Spiele sind da halt so, dass du mit einem Regelset diese verschiedenen Phasen der Entwicklung abbildest, ohne dass du jedes Mal neue Regeln einführen musst. Also diese Phase, wo ich meinen Charakter aufbaue, die Phase, wo ich das, was ich mir erarbeitet habe, auch ausnutze. Also ich bin jetzt mal, ich habe eine Mühle, dann kann ich Mehl malen, das ist so in der Mitte des Spiels, dann male ich ganz viel Mehl und dann irgendwann will ich das Mehl verkaufen und mir Siegpunkte schaffen. Also dass es so eine Veränderung im Spiel gibt, ohne dass du die Regeln änderst, das war zum Beispiel sehr toll. Und über diesen Stapelmechanismus passiert das dann eben auch. Ein sehr schönes Spiel, was jetzt erscheinen wird, demnächst ist auch Schwarzer Freitag, das simuliert so ein bisschen diesen Aktiensturz.
Die Finanzkrise als Brettspiel.
Genau, und das ist halt einfach fantastisch. Und das ist einfach fantastisch, wie das umgesetzt wurde, weil du diesen Drang förmlich spürst, ich muss noch kaufen, kaufen, kaufen, kaufen. Aber ich weiß, irgendwann kommt der Crash. Und eben diesen Zeitpunkt abzupassen, wann ich dann verkaufen muss.
Wodurch, wie wird denn der Crash ausgelöst?
Ja, das ist so ein Beutel, da sind Klötzchen drin und es gibt schwarze Klötzchen und Aktien. Das sind farbige Klötzchen. Und immer wenn schwarze Klötzchen rausgezogen werden, dann kommt der Crash näher. Und wenn eine gewisse Anzahl aus dem Beutel gezogen wurde, an schwarzen Klötzchen, dann ist der Crash da.
Aber was repräsentieren denn die Klötzchen?
Die schwarzen Klötzchen sind bloß eine Marke dafür, wann der Crash kommt, und die anderen Klötzchen sind die Aktien, die du kaufen kannst. Also es sind einfach bunte Klötzchen.
Aber das Spiel modelliert nicht wirklich jetzt die Eigenschaften der Blase in dem Sinne, sondern es ist mehr so ein random Element, wenn man damit schwarzen. Das ist mehr wie so ein Würfel, diese Klötzchen.
Ja, also diese Blase wird halt, also ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie sie es umsetzen werden. Diese Blase entsteht emotional, weil in der Blase werden ja die Aktien immer wertvoller. Und die werden auch in dem Spiel immer wertvoller. Und dieses Panikgefühl, zur richtigen Zeit aussteigen zu müssen, wird da sehr gut nachmodelliert. Und du hast den Vorteil, du weißt, dass der Crash kommt. Aber sind wir mal ehrlich, im echten Leben weißt du auch, dass der Crash kommt irgendwann. Nee, das stimmt ja.
Der ganze Markt funktioniert ja eigentlich nur deshalb, weil alle daran glauben, dass er funktioniert. Und in dem Moment, wo sie aufhören, daran zu glauben, hört er auch auf.
Ja, und nach jeder Blase wird wieder vergessen, dass er nicht funktioniert. Im Endeffekt, weil man es halt nicht glauben will. Und das Schöne daran ist, dass man in diesem Spiel sozusagen die Seite des Bösen einnimmt. Nämlich dem Verursacher.
Verstehe.
Aber man hat trotzdem diesen Spaß dran. Und erlebt es mit. Und das ist ja das, was auch in guten Filmen passiert, dass du dich dann in eine andere Rolle hineinversetzt und es durchlebst.
Teilweise auch mal in den Bösewicht.
Ja, teilweise auch in den Bösewicht. Also da noch die kleine Anekdote, die man immer erzählen muss, Monopoly. Da gab es ja einen Vorläufer dazu, war mal als antikapitalistisches Spiel geplant. Um eben dieses böse... Ja, das hat eine Frau erfunden, diesen Vorläufer. Und es war eben, um zu zeigen, ich glaube, Game of the Landlords hieß das, um zu zeigen, wie böse eigentlich der Kapitalismus ist.
Und jetzt ist es eigentlich so das Muster-Spiel, dass wir spielen Kapitalismus und es ist gut zu gewinnen. Was wurde dann auf den letzten Metern geändert? Oder hat sie sich aber anders aufgefasst?
Ich glaube, vom Spiel wurde nicht viel geändert. Es zeigt nur ganz schön, der Kapitalismus ist böse, aber er macht auch unglaublich viel Spaß für die, die gewinnen. Also insofern... Und da gibt es nämlich dann noch diesen anderen spannenden Effekt. Es gibt immer so große Bewegungen, wo sich Spiele hinbewegen. Also es ist ein evolutionärer Prozess. Es kommt ein Spiel raus, was so eine Duftmarke setzt. Zum Beispiel Siedler war eins davon. Und dann kommen Nachläufer, die das weiterentwickeln, dieses Thema vertiefen. Es gab mal so einen Trend, dass Kartenspiele ausgereist wurden. Also es gibt nicht bloß Stichkartenspiele, so wie Doppelkopf, sondern es gibt auch Kartenspiele, mit denen man ganz unterschiedliche Sachen machen kann. Eins meiner ersten Spiele war Verräter. Das hat sich angefühlt wie ein Brettspiel, aber war halt ein Kartenspiel in 60, reduziert auf 60 Karten. Und da ist ganz viel dann gekommen. Oder es gab einen relativ kurzen Trend von kooperativen Spielen, also wo alle gegen das Spiel spielen, zusammen. Zum Beispiel? Also Herr der Ringe zum Beispiel, das Brettspiel, da spielen ihm alle gegen Sauron.
Dem Bösen, des?
Genau. Genau. Und da gibt es immer mal wieder so neue Erfindungen sozusagen, die dann wieder aufgegriffen werden und einen neuen Bogen schaffen. Und spannend ist dabei, dass sich gewisse Erkenntnisse durchsetzen, was für ein Spielgut ist oder nicht. Und einer der wichtigsten Aspekte, finde ich, war dabei, die Trennung zwischen dem Geld, was du im Spiel hast, und den Siegpunkten, die du am Ende des Spiels hast, um zu gewinnen. Das heißt, ursprünglich war es so, ich bekomme Geld und wer das meiste Geld hat, gewinnt. Und diese Trennung in diese Einkommensseite und das, was ich dann eigentlich draus mache, hat dazu beigetragen, dass die Spiele interessanter geblieben sind während der Partie für die Leute, die weiter hinten waren. Denn ich konnte zum Beispiel sagen, okay, jeder von uns kriegt 50 Goldstücke pro Runde. Das heißt, wenn ich schlecht investiert habe, diese 50 Goldstücke, dann konnte ich trotzdem noch weiter mitspielen.
Ja, so eine Art Grundeinkommen.
Und genau darauf wollte ich hinaus, dass es eigentlich absurd, weil als ich dann vom bedingungslosen Grundeinkommen gehört habe, habe ich mir gedacht, mein Gott, in den Brettspielen machen wir das seit Jahren so. Weil es einfach die Marktteilnehmer im Spiel hält und denen weiter Spaß bereitet. Das hat mich dann wirklich zum Denken gebracht.
Ich meine, wir haben das ja vorhin schon gesagt, jetzt haben wir Kapitalismus gespielt, aber jetzt können wir auch ein neues Spiel aus dem Regal nehmen. Da sage ich schon, wie man den Karl-Marx-Spiel-Landschaft dann so auf den Tisch legt. Und dann spielt man halt mal so ein bisschen realer Sozialismus.
Das ist ganz spannend, weil es gibt dieses Spiel nicht, weil es keinen Spaß macht.
Gibt es nicht?
Es gibt Spiele, die das als Thema haben. Also Kreml zum Beispiel ist ein Kultspiel. Da musst du deine Kader so platzieren, dass die am Ende eben im Politbüro landen. Und die sind alle schon uralt und sterben dir weg. Also Satirisches Zeug gibt es schon. Aber ein Spiel, das so gemodelt wäre wie der Sozialismus, obwohl das könnte schon wieder spannend sein, einer legt so fest, was ist die Produktionsmenge und das wird dann produziert. Und man muss dann mit dem Scheiß was anfangen. Insofern kann man das schon wieder nachmodeln.
Wo bleibt denn das Brettspiel DDR?
Es gab ein unsägliches Brettspiel in den 90ern, das hieß überholen ohne einzuholen. Das war halt so ein Würfelaufspiel. Also auch wieder würfeln, Ereignis, bla. Aber das ist noch relativ unterentwickelt, dieses satirische Potenzial bei Brettspielen.
Es muss ja gar nicht satirisch sein, aber einfach dieses soziale Modell, einfach mal ein bisschen nachzuspielen. Man hat ja hier auch gerade DDR im CRI. Da gab es ja auch so ein paar lustige, da war ja auch meine Frage, ja, wie ist denn das so mit Privatwirtschaften? Im Prinzip konnte man das schon machen, solange man nicht mit dem System zu sehr in die Quere kam, etc. Und irgendwie so in einer Partei sein war nicht unbedingt immer nur wünschenswert, weil in dem Moment, wo man dann selbstständig ist und dann irgendwie noch eine Partei geht, dann fangen alle an, sich langsam zu fragen, was will denn der hier eigentlich? Also auch da gab es natürlich merkwürdige Regeln, wo es immer so eine spielerische Ausgewogenheit erfordert hat, um noch im Spiel zu bleiben. Von daher kam mir dann gerade dieser Gedanke, ich wollte eigentlich auf etwas anderes hinaus. Wenn du jetzt auch schon dieses Ding siehst mit ich entwickele meine Welt, die hat so ihre Regeln und ich versuche ein System zu finden, in dem alle glücklich sind. Und ich kann auch mal so etwas wie ein Grundeinkommen ausprobieren. Und ich kann auch Aspekte von Mord und Totschlag und keine Ahnung und sterben und geboren werden. Also so viele Dinge, die eben auch unser normales Leben bestimmen, dort abbilden. Kommt man dann nicht schon so langsam dann auch auf die Idee, so ein Brettspiel auch wirklich so als Testbett für gesellschaftliche Modelle auszuprobieren? Oder galoppiere ich jetzt irgendwie zu weit davon? Also wie viel Realität ist in so einem Spiel?
Sehr viel Realität. Also man kann sehr viele Erkenntnisse daraus ziehen. Das ist auch der Grund, warum wir seit ein paar Jahren die Spiele-Autoren-Tagung veranstalten, einmal im Jahr. Das ist so eine Art Kongress, wo wir eben über die Theorie der Spiele reden.
Also wer ist wir?
Das sind ein paar andere Autoren, mit denen ich mich zusammengetan habe und wir haben eben gesagt, es gibt so theoretisch noch nichts im Spielebereich, wo eben solche Erkenntnisse auch mal aufbereitet werden. Wir tun uns jetzt mal zusammen und veranstalten das und es hat auch sehr schön geklappt und wir bringen auch jedes Jahr ein Buch raus.
Das heißt, es ist jetzt mehr Forschung als Interessengemeinschaft?
Ja, es ist eigentlich mehr Forschung. Es geht natürlich auch darum, wie kann ich bessere Spiele entwickeln. Und dann diesen Schritt zu machen...
Diese Tagungen haben auch schon stattgefunden.
Genau, also die finden seit 2005, glaube ich, statt. Immer im März. Und sich dann zu überlegen, was sagt das eigentlich fürs Leben, das ist schon ganz interessant. Denn eigentlich kann man die Erkenntnisse aus dem Spielebereich auf alles anwenden, wo irgendwie ein offenes System da ist, wo man Menschen dazu bringen soll, was zu tun. Und wir versuchen halt immer, das System so zu gestalten, dass die Menschen es freiwillig tun. Weil wir haben keinen Zwang, ich kann niemanden zum Spielen zwingen. Und da gibt es halt auch wirklich spannende Spiele, die so zeigen, wie Menschen ticken. Also man lernt sehr genau, wie Menschen ticken. Das Spiel heißt Die Wehrwölfe von Düsterwald. Das sind einfach nur Karten, jeder bekommt eine Karte zugeteilt. Und es ist entweder ein Wehrwolf oder ein Dorfbewohner.
Das ist jetzt ein Spiel zum Kaufen? Das ist zum Kaufen, ja. Das gibt es richtig.
Genau, es ist ein Kartenspiel.
Also ihr macht ja jetzt nicht eure eigenen Spiele nur zum Forschen?
Wir haben auch schon ein Spiel gemacht zum Forschen. Wir haben ein Spiel gemacht zum Forschen, ein Spiel ohne Spielanleitung. Das heißt einfach, was sich selber erschließt. Also dieser GUI-Aspekt ist bei Brettspielen auch immer sehr wichtig, weil wir viele Informationen übertragen müssen oder vermitteln müssen, ohne sie aufzuschreiben, weil die Leute ungern Spielanleitungen lesen. Wäre ich jetzt auch so zurückgekommen, also die Werwölfe funktioniert so. Jeder bekommt eine Karte, Wolf oder Dorfbewohner. Dann schließen, es gibt einen Moderator, der das Spiel leitet. Alle schließen die Augen. Es ist nachts und die Dorf- und die Wölfe öffnen die Augen und bestimmen einen aus der Runde, den sie umbringen wollen. Dann schließen alle wieder die Augen und der Moderator sagt, wer gestorben ist. Und dann dürfen alle diskutieren, tagsüber, wer könnte jetzt ein Werwolf sein? Den hängen wir. Also alle diskutieren, ich habe hier was gehört. Oder der verhält sich verdächtig oder der hat was gesagt, oder der kichert oder der sagt gar nichts. Der ist ein Werwolf. Und alle Dorfbewohner, inklusive der Werwölfe, die tun ja so, als wären sie Dorfbewohner, dürfen dann einen bestimmen, der auch rausfliegt. Das alterniert dann immer, Nacht und Tag und Nacht und Tag. Und es gewinnen entweder die Dorfbewohner oder die Wölfe.
Das ist so Hälfte, Hälfte oder was?
Nee, es sind wesentlich weniger Wölfe als Dorfbewohner, sonst wäre es unfähig. Und es ist wirklich interessant, wie die Leute so agieren und sich...
So ein bisschen so Hexenverfolgung, ne?
Das hat was von Hexenverfolgung, ja. Und auch, wer schweigt, macht sich verdächtig. Aber wer laut schreit, macht sich noch viel verdächtiger. Und interessant wird es dann auch, wenn es so in die Spieltheorie auch reingeht. Wie verhalten sich Spieler über verschiedene Runden hinweg, wenn sie sich gegenseitig vertrauen müssen? Also wir machen ein Deal, du musst dich aber nicht dran halten, kannst dich aber dran halten. Und wenn ich weiß, das Spiel geht zehn Runden, dann in den ersten Runden werde ich mich wahrscheinlich an den Deal halten, um Vertrauen aufzubauen. Und dann so zum Ende hin ist es für mich besser, den Deal einfach zu brechen, weil es gibt keine Konsequenzen mehr. Bei Risiko gibt es auch immer diese Allianzen. Also wir zusammen jetzt gegen den Grünen. Und dann sieht man ganz gut, wann bricht die wieder auseinander und so. Also es zeigt sehr viel über die Natur des Menschen. Und auch über, man lernt sehr stark die anderen kennen, wenn man mit ihnen spielt.
Entlarvend.
Ja, spielen ist entlarvend. Deswegen machen das auch manche ungern aus diesem Grund.
Weil sie dann zu viel von sich preisgeben auf einmal.
Ja, und viele Hobby-Spieler lustigerweise haben eher Angst vor dieser Kommunikation. Deswegen spielen die dann eher Strategie, Hammer, wo sich dann alles im Spiel abspielt, aber nicht in der Metaebene. Dabei ist die Metaebene total wichtig für ein Spiel. Welche Kommunikation funktioniert darüber? Und das wird oft auch vergessen bei Regelsystemen generell. Wenn irgendwas sich überlegt wird, dann denkt man sich, oh, das funktioniert so und dann gibt es dieses Verbot und dieses Gebot und so. Aber die Metaebene wird nicht mit einbezogen. Das heißt, die Schlupflöcher, fast jede Regel hat ja irgendwelche Schlupflöcher. Oder wie fühlen sich die Leute emotional dabei? Also was passiert dann da eigentlich, was nicht mehr in diesem Regelsystem ist, sondern außenrum? Nehmen wir mal den Straßenverkehr, rote Ampel. Im Idealfall bleiben alle Menschen an der roten Ampel stehen.
Ist ja verboten.
Ja, ist aber nicht so. Bleiben sie gar nicht. Sondern da passiert noch viel, was nicht in dem Regelsystem drin ist, aber wichtig für das, wie ich es regle. Und das muss man bei Brettspielen auch immer mit einbeziehen, wenn man was entwickelt. Wie verhält es sich in Wirklichkeit?
Das heißt, bei der Fachtagung geht es vor allem auch viel. Da geht es nicht schon ein bisschen in Sozial- und Verhaltungsforschung mit rein. Also ich habe jetzt so Bilder vor Augen von Kindern, Fünfjährigen, die irgendwelchen Tests unterzogen werden, um herauszufinden, wie sie eigentlich so drauf sind und wann sie so verstanden haben, wie man jemanden hintergeht etc. Das ist ja schon nahezu wissenschaftliche Arbeit.
Also es ist meistens so, dass die Sachen vorbereitet sind für die Fachtagung. Also die Experimente finden da gar nicht immer statt, sondern oft sind es Vorträge darüber, was habe ich in diesem letzten Jahr so gelernt über Spiele erfinden. Wird auch gespielt? Am Anfang haben wir gesagt, wir wollen so wenig wie möglich spielen und wir halten es auch durch. Abends wird dann ein bisschen gespielt. Aber es geht eben nichts ums Spielen, weil Spiele treffen gibt es genug. Es ging explizit darum, sich Gedanken darüber zu machen und du kommst aus dieser Tagung raus und denkst dir, wow, ich habe die und die und die und die Idee. Und das Schöne ist dann auch immer, Sachen zu denken, die noch keiner vorher gedacht hat. Also Regeln zu brechen. Ein Spiel zu machen, was eigentlich so nicht machbar ist. Zum Beispiel habe ich auf der letzten Tagung so einen Spontan-Workshop gemacht. Spiele, die sich selbst tarieren. Ich weiß nicht, ob das Wort tarieren jetzt so...
Ausgleichen.
Wahnsinnig verbreitet ist, genau. Gemeint damit ist, die Stellschrauben einzustellen bei einem Spiel. Wenn ich ein Spiel entwickle, ist es oft so, das funktioniert alles sehr schön, aber ich muss Preise festlegen. Und Material, wie viele Spielfiguren hat der Spieler und so was. Das ist immer eine unglaublich große Arbeit, das zu tun. Und dann habe ich gedacht, wie wäre es denn mal, ein Spiel zu machen, was das automatisch tut? Im Computerspielbereich kennt man das von künstlicher Intelligenz, die lernt, die sich dann anpasst auf den... Bei Brettspielen das zu simulieren, ist natürlich viel schwerer. Wie kann ich schauen, dass ein Brettspiel sich selber anpasst? Also das sind da neue Dimensionen. Und das ist wahrscheinlich der Grund, warum ich auch beim Brettspiel gelandet bin. Weil es ein Feld ist, was noch so lustigerweise so jung ist, dass du noch unglaublich viel entdecken kannst. Und unglaublich viel machen kannst, was noch keiner vorher gemacht hat. Und deswegen spiele ich eigentlich fast jedes neue Spiel, was so auf dem Markt kommt, höchstens einmal, weil mich schon wieder das neue interessiert. Was kommt da noch?
Na ja, bei 300 bis 400 Spielen pro Jahr muss man sich auch ganz schön dranhalten.
Ja, und da gibt es dann halt auch Ideen, die dich dann vom Sockel wehren.
Lässt sich denn so ein Brettspiel im Computer simulieren? Gibt es schon so komplexe Systeme? Oder hat man manchmal so den Eindruck, dass ich jetzt mal am Computer durchspiele, welche Möglichkeiten sich da so ergeben, um zu gucken, ob meine Regeln überhaupt hinhauen? Oder sind sie zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo man so eine Verdächtigung hat, eigentlich schon zu kompliziert?
Also so, dass der Computer richtig mitspielen könnte, ist sehr schwer. Und es gibt leider erste Ansätze, so Brettspiel-Simulatoren zu machen, wo du wenigstens das Material nachbauen kannst, dass du mit dem Computer was ausrechnen kannst und ausprobieren kannst. Aber es ist noch nicht sehr verbreitet. Computer könnten schon eine große Stütze sein für die Entwicklung von Brettspielen. Normalerweise funktioniert das so, dass du dir erst mal ein Spiel ausdenkst, im Kopf hin und her wendest, bis es keine Lücken mehr hat. Auch wichtig, Spieleautoren haben die große Fähigkeit, in einem System die Lücken zu entdecken. Also manche Dinge, die so gemacht werden, werden einem Spieleautor nicht untergekommen. Weil er sofort gesehen hätte, okay, da gibt es eine Lücke, da werden sich alle drauf stürzen. Weil jede Lücke, die es gibt, wird ausgenutzt. Und ich finde es total infam, ein Regelsystem zu machen und sich darüber aufzuregen, dass die Leute die Lücke ausnutzen. Das wird ja oft gemacht, die sind dann empört.
Wie zum Beispiel so bei unseren Gesetzen. Hier irgendwie Hartz IV-Horster in Florida oder wie hieß er?
Ja, also das ist dämlich. Ich muss damit rechnen, dass die benutzt wird, die Lücke. Interessant ist, manchmal ist der soziale Druck im Spiel, am Tisch so groß, dass die Lücke dann nicht ausgenutzt wird, obwohl man sie ausnutzen dürfte. Also diese Metaebene spielt immer mit. Wie wollen die Leute eigentlich miteinander spielen? Das merkt man ganz gut bei Kommunikationen.
Es gibt ja auch ein paar Computerspielen. Im CCC wird Nintendo 64 Mario Kart gespielt, wo es natürlich auch in jeder Runde die Möglichkeit gibt, dann mal eine kleine Abkürzung zu machen. Diese Ausnutzung der Abkürzung ist dann auch schon etwas verwerflich. Man hat sich halt explizit darauf geeinigt.
Dieser Peer-Pressure ist heutzutage sehr wichtig. Wichtiger wahrscheinlich als die Regeln. Bei kommunikativen Spielen merkt man es oft. Dass oft das Regelwerk in den Hintergrund tritt. Für die Vielspieler muss man trotzdem ein funktionierendes Regelwerk entwerfen. Jetzt hatte ich aber irgendwie so einen Strang aufgemacht, den ich noch weiterführen wollte, nämlich wie so ein Spiel entsteht. Ich habe es im Kopf, dann baue ich einen Prototypen, also ein Spiel, was im realen Leben existiert, aus Pappe, aus Karton, mit kleinen Holzfiguren, und teste das erstmal mit mir selbst. Das ist diese Phase, wo du angeregt hast, da könnte man ja vielleicht einen Computer benutzen. Man spielt erstmal mit sich selbst, weil man das nicht anderen Leuten zumuten möchte, also jeden Scheiß, der vielleicht gar nicht funktioniert. Und da erkennt man auch meistens so die groben Fehler, also was passt zusammen und was nicht. Und wenn das ein paar Mal funktioniert, dann lehrt man sich so eine Runde ein und spielt es mit anderen Spielern. Spielt und kriegt Feedback, verändert, verbessert, spielt und kriegt Feedback, das ist so ein langer Prozess. Die Beta-Phase, als Spieler hat man nicht so viele Beta-Tester wie bei einem Computerspiel normalerweise.
Ja, was hast du denn so für Spiele gemacht?
Da ich das Neue so gern mag, habe ich eine große Bandbreite. Also ich habe, wie gesagt, Verräter gemacht. Das ist eigentlich eine verrückte Idee, ein strategisches Brettspiel in 60 Karten umzusetzen. Aber ich mag diese Denkbeschränkungen immer sehr gern beim Entwickeln, weil man dann zu neuen Lösungen kommt.
Achso, du wolltest sagen, die Anzahl der Karten limitieren.
Genau, ich hatte sozusagen die Vorgabe, ich habe 60 Karten und muss da ein Spiel machen, was sich anfühlt, als wäre es ein Brettspiel mit Figuren und allem Möglichen. So etwas lockt bei mir immer die Kreativität. Dann habe ich ein Wortspiel gemacht, wo man so Assoziationen machen muss. Also man muss sozusagen in die gleiche Richtung denken. Das hat so funktioniert, ich sage einen Begriff zum Beispiel Apple und habe dann so Karten auf der Hand, waschmaschinenfest, grün, teuer und so weiter und lege diese Karten aus. Und die anderen müssen jetzt in meinen Gehirn reingucken und überlegen, finde ich, dass es zu dem Begriff Apple passt oder finde ich, dass es nicht zu dem Begriff Apple passt. Also waschmaschinenfest ist er sicher nicht. Apple Computer, genau. Apple oder ein Apfel.
Ja gut.
Ja, aber zum Beispiel, das ist auch wieder interessant, weil ich sage Apple und was denkst du wieder? Also man muss ein bisschen in die gleiche Richtung denken und das führt immer zu interessanten Situationen, weil viel gelacht wird und dann jemand sagt, was? Ich habe meinen Apple Computer schon fünf mal durchgewaschen, funktioniert immer noch super. Dann haben wir ein Malspiel gemacht.
Wir? Das heißt, du machst auch immer alles alleine?
Genau, es gibt auch Kooperationen. Es wird immer beliebter, weil man einfach zu zweit schneller zu dem Punkt kommt, weil man so die Bälle hin und her spielen kann. Ich mache viele Spiele alleine, aber so ein, zwei Kooperationen habe ich auch gemacht. Da würde ich fast sagen, das Highlight, fiese Freunde, fette Feten. Das ist mein politisch inkorrektes Spiel. Wobei ich jetzt schon wieder sagen würde, hier unter intelligenten Menschen, das ist schon wieder politisch korrekt. Du kannst nämlich, also es simuliert das Leben, wie das Spiel des Lebens, plus ein bisschen strategischer. Und du kannst während deines Lebens eben auch Sex haben, und zwar mit jedem beliebigen anderen Spieler, egal welchen Geschlechts. Und auch mit fiktiven anderen Spielern, die im Spiel vorkommen. Und du durchschreitest dein Leben und hast Lebensziele. Also Standard-Dinger wie Millionär werden, eine Sekte gründen, vom Glauben abfallen. Die haben bestimmte Voraussetzungen, die du erreichen willst. Also wenn du zum Beispiel Millionär werden willst, musst du Geld kriegen. Wenn du Fett absaugen willst, musst du fett werden. Und dann spielst du halt so die Pubertät. In der Pubertät ist alles einfach, da kriegst du alles geschenkt. Da gehst du einfach mal, hast einen One-Night-Stand, und dann hattest du schon Sex. Oder du schaust fern und wirst schon dick und dumm. Und später wird es dann immer schwieriger, weil du brauchst Voraussetzungen. Also wenn ich jetzt auf der Jacht fahren will, dann muss ich schon mal Geld haben und so weiter. Und so arbeite ich mich zu meinen verrückten Zielen hin und versuche eben, diese Ziele zu erfüllen. Und das Besondere an dem Spiel war, dass eine Geschichte entsteht. Also am Ende des Spiels habe ich wirklich ein Leben gelebt und jedes Mal ein anderes. Und da gibt es auch eine nette Anekdote, hat mir dann einer erzählt, der hatte dann mit allen im Spiel Sex. Nur mit einer nicht und die waren ziemlich stinkig nach dem Spiel. Und dann haben sie es im echten Leben nachgeholt. Also ich mache sehr verschiedene Sachen.
Okay, kann man auf jeden Fall nicht behaupten, das hätte jetzt irgendwie keinen realen Bezug zum normalen Leben. Aber das kann mir auch gerade so. Ich meine, wenn man jetzt so solche Sachen macht, dann muss man ja auch eine Menge an kulturellem Input tanken, denke ich mir. Also wenn man nicht dann auch sehr weit über den eigenen Tellerrand hinausblickt, man rührt ja im Prinzip so ein gesellschaftliches Potpourri von Aktivitäten, von Charakteren, Eigenschaften. Die muss man ja auch alle irgendwie so ein bisschen spüren und vielleicht auch ein Stück weit selbst erlebt haben, um nicht zu sehr immerhin sich in Klischees zu bewegen.
Also den Standard-Satz, den Brettspiel-Entwickler zu hören bekommen ist, da könntest du noch mal ein Spiel draus machen. Ich glaube, das kennt man immer. Ja, Tim, bei dir heißt es dann, ach, da könntest du auch mal einen Podcast hören machen. Also dieses alles draufziehen. Aber es funktioniert wirklich so, man kann aus allem irgendwas rausziehen und dann wieder verarbeiten. In der Schlange stehen, sich darüber... Wie könnte man besser in der Schlange stehen verteilen, darüber ein Spiel zu machen?
Sozusagen die Wartezeit verkürzen, ne? Das alte Problem, wo stelle ich mich an?
Also alles, was Probleme sind in der Gesellschaft, eignet sich gut für ein Spiel. Und wenn es gut läuft, findet man da sogar Lösungen am Ende, die irgendwie befriedigend sind. Also es hat...
Vordrängeln.
Wo der soziale Aspekt wieder dann ist.
Was für Strategien schlägt man da an?
Also es hat zum Beispiel jemand aus dieser Fabel, von der Salomonischen Teilung, hat dann auch einfach ein Spiel daraus gemacht, weil es ein schöner Mechanismus ist. Ich kriege so ein Set von Karten und ich darf sie aufteilen in zwei Sets. Du darfst aussuchen, welche Karten du nimmst. Hat gut funktioniert. Also auch so diese ganzen Geschichten und was so im echten Leben rumfleucht, an Sachen lassen sich auch manchmal gut für Spielemechanismen benutzen.
Da bildet sich ja jetzt noch eine ziemliche Bandbreite an Ideen und so weiter, an lustigen Dingen. Ich bin jetzt kein besonders Computerspiele-erfahrener Mensch. Ich bin auch immer etwas zynisch, indem ich sage, es gibt eigentlich nur drei Computerspiele. Da wo man die Prinzessin retten muss, da wo man irgendwie alle umbringen muss und das mit dem Auto. Da hat man schon mal 90 Prozent abgehängt.
Da ich nur Adventures gespielt habe.
Ja, genau. Mir ging das auch so. Ich bin eigentlich ein bisschen spieleragnostisch, aber Text-Adventures fand ich aber wiederum ganz toll. In diese ganzen Strategie und Multi-User-Spiele bin ich nie so richtig reingekommen, aber ich will jetzt auch gar nicht über mich reden. Was mich interessiert ist, wie siehst du da jetzt die Kreativität gestreut im Computerspiele-Bereich und wo sind da die Verbindungen zwischen der Computerspiele-Welt, die ja auch teilweise extrem kreativ ist und die natürlich auch noch ganz andere Möglichkeiten hat und auch ganz andere Dinge bewältigen kann. Wo ein Brettspiel den Vorteil hat, dass man richtige Menschen in einem Raum hat, man kann sich irgendwie angucken und miteinander lachen versus eben die ganzen Vorteile, die diese Computerspiel-Konzepte mit sich bringen.
Also ich muss dazu sagen, ich bin bei den Computerspielen ausgestiegen, als es mit meinem Amiga vorbei war. Also da habe ich noch viel gespielt und ich habe auch als Kind immer versucht, die als Brettspiel umzusetzen. Also Maniac Mansion zum Beispiel habe ich dann mir so einen Plan gebaut und versuchte es irgendwie nachzusimulieren. Weil vielleicht bin ich auch zu den Brettspielen gekommen, weil ich nicht programmieren konnte da richtig. Und habe dann halt das gemacht, was ich machen konnte. Und danach habe ich die Brettspiele...
Ja, aber du machst doch eigentlich genau das Gleiche. Ich meine, das was du da eben beschrieben hast, so wie, was weiß ich, ich kann ein guter Brettspieler findet irgendwie alle Lücken. Man muss das ganze System im Kopf durchgehen. Man schafft sich irgendwie ein Regelsystem und man denkt das dann mit Handlungsabläufen durch. Dann hat man so eine Debugging-Phase, wo man das alles austestet. Man spielt es irgendwie mit Sicht. Dann hat man seine Beta-Tester. Ich meine, da hätten wir jetzt auch zehn Minuten lang gerade über Programmieren reden können. Da wären keine anderen Worte gefallen. Gibt da schon irgendwie die ganze Menge Berührungspunkte?
Die gibt es auf jeden Fall. Ich denke, zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo ich ausgestiegen bin und wo ich auch die Entwicklung der Computerspiele eher negativ gesehen habe, war halt, dass plötzlich die Grafik und der Sound so in den Vordergrund gerückt sind und die 3D-Engines und so. Und selbst die absurdesten Spiele, die total Spaß gemacht haben, mussten plötzlich 3D werden, obwohl es gar keinen Sinn gemacht hat, also gerade bei den Adventures. Und ich glaube, dann gab es eine ganz lange Phase, wo die Spielmechanismen selber in den Hintergrund gerückt sind. Und leider bin ich da dann ausgestiegen. Das heißt, ich weiß nicht, wo die Computerspiele mittlerweile sind.
Aber ich habe schon den Eindruck, dass sich das jetzt langsam wieder ändert, nicht? Weil jetzt ist das so mit dem 3D langsam, atmen alle wieder ein bisschen aus. Also ich frage so Multi-User und das Miteinanderspiel, nicht World of Warcraft etc. Das sind ja auch alles Systeme, die im Prinzip deiner Beschreibung auch gehorchen. Da gibt es halt irgendwie Regelsysteme, man hat Ressourcen, man macht Handel. Ja, das sind ja alles Elemente, die dort einen ganz großen Reiz ausmachen.
Also ich habe auch damals zwei Vorträge an der Games Academy gehalten, die ja Computerspiele-Entwickler ausbilden in Berlin über Brettspiele. Da habe ich mich auch ein bisschen so gefühlt, die machen jetzt Animationsfilme und ich sage ihnen, wie man die zehn Geburte in Steintafeln meißelt. Aber das fand ich ja auch wichtig. Man lernt ja auch natürliches Zeichnen, bevor man dann im Kunstunterricht weitergeht. Ich glaube, die Berührungspunkte sind eigentlich groß, weil man das Gleiche machen muss, genauso wie du sagst. Man muss das Spiel halt designen und sich überlegen, wie interagiert es und so weiter. Beim Brettspiel hast du halt immer die Beschränkung, was ist technisch möglich. Und das ist sehr wenig, weil der menschliche Geist nicht so viele Register hat, wo er Werte speichern kann und so. Du musst eigentlich fast alles immer auch im Brett festhalten, den Stand, wo wir gerade sind. Und deswegen musst du uns halt immer destillieren, die Ideen, die du hast und kürzen. Und es sind auch viele lustige mechanische Entwicklungen dadurch entstanden. Von Sachen, die einfach was simulieren, einen Zustand festhalten können oder einen Zustand erzeugen. Es gab so einen Turm, wo du dann Würfel reinwürfst als neuer Zufallsgenerator, der nicht mehr ganz so Zufall ist, weil es ja davon abhängt, welche Würfel schon in diesem Turm drinstecken. Also der war ein bisschen verwinkelt innen drin. Also manchmal denkt man sich einfach neue Sachen aus, dann mechanisch. Beim Computerspiel hast du die ganz große Freiheit. Und eigentlich ist es schade, dass die Berührungspunkte so gering sind zwischen diesen beiden Branchen. Deswegen habe ich auch da ein bisschen in Kontakt gesucht damals. Brettspielentwickler arbeiten halt anders, weil da nicht diese Budgets dahinter stecken. Also die Verantwortung zu haben, da so ein Zehn-Millionen-Dollar-Projekt umzusetzen, die möchte ich als Brettspielentwickler nicht haben. Als Brettspielentwickler bin ich frei. Denn im Normalfall kriege ich auch keinen Auftrag, sondern ich entwickle das, was mir Spaß macht, das, was ich machen möchte. Und gehe dann zu einem Verlag und sage, hey, hast du Lust, das zu machen?
Das ist eigentlich mehr Erfinder. Das ist wieder ein ursprüngliches Wort.
Ja, genau. Und die arbeiten natürlich auch noch dran und versuchen das dann zu verbessern und dann kommt das auf den Markt. Aber ich bin nicht gebunden und bis zu diesem Zeitpunkt habe ich wirklich zehn Euro für Material reingesteckt und natürlich meine Zeit. Bei einem Computerspiel sieht das anders aus. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das so funktioniert, wie die ihre Konzepte entwickeln. Also mal abgesehen von denen, du nimmst ein altes Computerspiel und überlegst dir, was du da noch drauf machen kannst.
Aber du warst ja jetzt auch gerade, können wir auch mal erwähnen, hier aktiv in die Umsetzung eines Brettspiels auf dem Computer eingebunden. Eben das schon erwähnte Carcassonne, das hier unsere Freunde und Kollegen aus München umgesetzt haben. Und da warst du aber auch gestalterisch mit tätig.
Da kann man sehen, wie es ganz gut funktionieren kann.
Also regelgestalterisch.
Genau. Also es ging um die Solovariante. Da hatte Dominik einen Entwurf gemacht von der. Und ich habe einfach als Spieleautor drüber geguckt und gesagt, hier und hier und hier und hier.
Also normalerweise spielt man das halt mit mehreren anderen und wollte sozusagen einen Modus schaffen, wo man es alleine spielen kann.
Genau, also eine neue Erfindung, die Solovariante für Carcassonne, die man alleine spielen kann. Und dann haben wir eben darüber diskutiert, was muss aus spielerischer Sicht da drin sein, damit es eben Spaß macht und funktioniert. Und ja, diese Rolle habe ich dann eben übernommen, sozusagen das Spiel, diese einen da noch mal umzustellen.
Was heißt Solo? Aber nicht, dass man gegen Computer spielt?
Na so, es funktioniert ein bisschen so wie eine Passions-Legen. Das kennen ja alle von diesem PC-Spiel, was ich nicht gespielt habe, weil ich nie ein PC besessen habe in meinem Leben.
Ja, aber ich habe schon mal Passions gespielt. Das kann man ja auch ohne Computer spielen.
Genau. Du kriegst einfach Karten und musst sie anlegen und es muss so gut gelegt werden, dass eben ein Ergebnis auskommt. Genau. Und das eben so zu designen, dass eine gewisse Dynamik drin ist, dass die Variabilität groß genug ist von Partie zu Partie und dass eben auch der Wiederspielreiz da ist. Wiederspielreiz ist ein Buzzword im Brettspielbereich, obwohl es manchmal einmal ist. Viele Spiele werden halt nur einmal gespielt. Da muss der Wiederspielreiz gar nicht so toll sein. Der heißt eigentlich, dass ein Spiel Tiefe hat, dass man es entdecken kann über die Partien und dass es nicht langweilig wird. Dadurch. Und das ist vielleicht auch was, was ich sehr reizvoll finde an Spielen, dass ich ein Produkt schaffe mit meiner Erfindung, das dann bastle, aber ich habe es selber noch nicht erfahren. Was ich damit meine, ist, wenn ich ein Buch schreibe, dann kenne ich das Buch vorher, dann weiß ich, wie die Geschichte endet. Wenn ich ein Spiel mache, habe ich zwar eine Vorstellung, aber ich weiß nie, wie es sich spielen wird. Also das ist eher wie ein Baby kriegen, du weißt nicht, was dann da rauskommt. Und dann hast du deine Freude selber an deinem eigenen Produkt. Das ist, glaube ich, was Ungewöhnliches für so künstlerische Sachen.
Du hast vorhin erwähnt, also eine der Sachen, wo du so ein bisschen ausgeholt hast und ich dich wieder eingefangen habe, aber das wollen wir mal hier durchaus noch mal angehen, Stichwort GUI und Selbsterklärende Spielanleitungen. Also üblicherweise ist es ja schon so, dass so ein Brettspiel mit nicht wenig Regelwerk daherkommt. Man muss halt dann irgendwie erst mal so fünf, sechs Seiten lesen, beim einen mehr, beim anderen weniger, um eben nichts falsch zu machen. Ist das jetzt irgendwie so eine Eigenschaft einiger Spiele, oder dass es generell etwas fehlt und was mal so ein Trend sein sollte, dass die Spiele mehr selbsterklärend sind?
Also es ist der große Pferdefuß an den Spielen momentan, dass du dich immer durch diese Anleitung quälen musst.
Gerade für so Einmal-Spieler.
Manche Leute haben schon keine Lust, einen sechsseitigen Text zu lesen, eine sechsseitige Anleitung. Vor allem die Anleitungen sind so geschrieben, dass sie viele Spiele haben, sofort verstehen, weil immer die gleichen Begriffe verwendet werden. Aber so ein Laie hat da Probleme. Und deswegen habe ich letztes Jahr einen Workshop gemacht, da zu sprechendes Material sozusagen. Ein gutes Spielbrett und ein gutes Spielmaterial verrät dir schon 90 Prozent der Regel. Nehmen wir jetzt zum Beispiel Risiko. Da gibt es Würfel, die sind rot und Würfel, die sind blau. Und die einen sind für Angriff und die einen sind für Verteidigung. Ist logisch, welche welche sind, oder? Genau, rotes Angriff. Das ist zum Beispiel gutes Design. Das haben sie übrigens auch geändert in Risiko. Früher waren die nicht rot und blau. Aber solche kleinen Hints sind ganz gut. Oder ich habe Spielfiguren, die sind rund. Und ich habe Spielfiguren, die sind eckig. Und dann habe ich einen Spielplan, da gibt es Runde. Es gibt viele Felder und eckige Felder. Es ist sofort klar, wohin es gehört. Solche kleinen Sachen helfen den Spielern, das Spiel zu begreifen. Deswegen liegt mir User-Interface auch immer sehr am Herzen. Das kann sich auch alles gegenseitig befruchten. Sowohl für Computer als auch für den Brettspielbereich. Da gibt es auch Probleme mit den Farbenblinden. Man muss immer darauf aufpassen, dass Sachen nicht nur farbkodiert sind.
Accessibility sozusagen.
Farbkodierung ist sehr verbreitet in Spielen. Das kennt jeder aus. Mensch, ärgere dich nicht. Rot, blau, grün, gelb. Rot und grün hast du schon ein Problem, wenn du nicht die Helligkeit unterschiedlich machst. Da ist auch ein Bewusstsein entstanden. Das hat auch etwas damit zu tun, dass die Produktionsmittel einfach besser geworden sind. Man kann mehr Rücksicht nehmen auf gewisse Sachen. Spielregeln waren früher schwarz-weiß, wenn sie nicht im Schachteldeckel gedruckt waren. Man bemüht sich schon.
Wobei der Schachteldeckel den großen Vorteil hat, dass man sie nicht so einfach verlieren könnte.
Man kann sie heute schon als PDF runterladen. Da muss ich dringend auf eine Website hinweisen, die das Mekka der Informationen über Spiele ist. Wenn du in die Website kommst, da findest du über jedes Spiel Informationen. Spielregeln, Bilder zu dem Spiel, wann ist das erschienen usw.
Das ist dann noch ein Boardgame-Geek.
Ganz lustig, dass erst die Amis kommen mussten, um so ein Portal aufzubauen.
Merkwürdig, das können sie dann wieder besser.
Da hat Deutschland schon sehr geschlafen. Muss man ganz ehrlich sagen.
Ui weia, das ist aber voll mit Fu. Ist das alles Englisch?
Alles Englisch.
Also das ist eine hartes Thema in der deutschen Variante.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die noch kommen wird. Ich hatte das Gefühl, dass die deutschen Spieler nicht ganz so internetaffin waren. Jetzt gibt es langsam ein paar Blogs, die sich mit Spielen beschäftigen.
Denkst du, dass der Brettspiel-Spieler dann auch wirklich so ein Internet-Agnostiker ist?
Nein, Internet-Agnostiker würde ich jetzt nicht sagen. Aber jetzt auch nicht der Early Adopter.
So ein Offline-Typ.
Nein, nein. Ich sage immer, es gibt so viele Arten von Geeks. Und Brettspiel-Geeks sind nochmal anders als die Rollenspiel-Geeks und anders als die Computerspiel-Nerds usw. Klar ist die Szene recht offline basiert. Ich habe es gemerkt, es gibt einmal im Jahr eine große Spielemesse in Essen. Das ist die größte Publikumsmesse weltweit.
Spiel.
Und da war auf Twitter nicht viel los. Normalerweise, wenn du so ein Event hast, dann geht es ab.
Verstehe, das hatte ich neulich bei einer Buchtagung in Berlin. Da konnte man auch an zwei Fingern abzählen, wer da getwittert hat.
Aber ich glaube, das ändert sich gerade. Aber was das Elektronische angeht, sind die Spiele schon manchmal ein bisschen hinterher. Also zum Beispiel die Verlage haben das Twitter gar nicht für sich entdeckt. Und Facebook ist da auch sehr stiefmütterlich.
Haben den Brettspieler schon in der Regel ihre eigene Homepage so?
Nee, die Verlage haben alle Homepages. Da sind die Informationen aber sehr dürftig. Nur die herausragenden haben irgendwie Homepages.
Aber ist das nicht eine große Chance auch, das Netz? Also ich meine, ich denke jetzt an zweierlei. Einerseits das Netz quasi so als, ja, ich will jetzt nicht soziales Netzwerk sagen, aber halt so ein bisschen als Informationsdrehscheibe rumtum das Spiel. So für Anregungen, Variantenbildung, Regelvarianten etc. Ich meine, ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das bei diesem Boardgame-Geek quasi schon das Konzept ist. Das ist es wahrscheinlich. Aber dann eben sozusagen auch für den Hersteller, denke ich mal, gibt es da auch noch mehr abzuholen. Nächste Geschichte ist natürlich, was ist mit Adaptionen von Brettspielen auf dem Computer? Um sich eben seine Mitspieler nicht unbedingt im selben Raum suchen zu müssen. Man hat ja gesagt, USA hing es eben dann sehr auch einfach an der Größe und der Weitläufigkeit des Landes. Schreit doch geradezu nach Computer mit Netzen, oder?
Also ohne das Netz wäre der Markt wahrscheinlich halb so groß. Weil dann gäbe es wahrscheinlich auch nur noch den deutschen Markt und die anderen wären marginal. Interessant ist da die Mentalitätsfrage. In den USA gibt es eine unglaubliche Fan-Kultur. Die gibt es in Deutschland nicht. Da geht es meistens darum, ja, die finden ein Spiel toll und spielen es auch, aber die gehen nicht raus und stellen sich hin, hier, ich habe das tollste Spiel der Welt gespielt, wisst ihr alle, guckt mal her. Und das machen die Amis. Die beißen sich da fest an einem Spiel und promoten das richtig und pushen das. Und das ist glaube ich auch der Grund, warum der amerikanische Markt so schnell gewachsen ist. Weil die machen das wie Tupper und versuchen andere zu bekehren zum Brettspiel. Da ist der deutsche ein bisschen anders.
Ja, ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen, mit so einem Hase-
und Igel-T-Shirt durch die Pusgange zu laufen. Ohne Netz wäre das wahrscheinlich auch nicht gegangen.
Na gut, aber ich meine, was ist jetzt mit Adaption? Ich meine, wenn mit Brettspielen schon so viel Überlegung reingeflossen ist in Bezug auf das Austarieren der Regeln und dass das eben sozusagen auch sozial funktioniert, dann sind das doch eigentlich ideale Vorlagen für Computerspiele. Oder passt da wieder irgendwas nicht? Oder sind die Regeln nur geeignet, wenn man in einem Raum sitzt?
Also prinzipiell gebe ich dir Recht. Es gibt auch die Brettspielwelt, da kann man online gegeneinander spielen. Das sind 1 zu 1 Umsetzungen.
Ein Schach ist ja nun ein Netz. Auch ein gutes Beispiel.
Mit den Umsetzungen ist es so eine Sache. Oft wurde nicht verstanden, was man da so macht. Nicht alle Brettspiele sind geeignet für Computer. Und wenn sie umgesetzt wurden, dann meistens schlecht. Das heißt, ich mache da halt jetzt 3D drauf. Völlig unsinnig. Es geht erstmal darum, gut auszuwählen, was ist überhaupt geeignet. Was will ich auch am Computer mit anderen spielen? Dann zweitens, welche Plattform habe ich? Ist das der PC oder ist das das iPhone zum Beispiel? Will ich online spielen oder gemeinsam am Brett mit diesen Touch-Devices, wenn ich die auf den Tisch lege, das könnte ja auch irgendwie interessant sein, da was zu machen. Weil ich halt mehr Möglichkeiten habe, durch das Computerisierte. Und ich muss es leider sagen, aber die einzige Umsetzung, die mich bislang überzeugt hat, war wirklich dieses Carcassonne. Weil die sich nicht überlegt haben, wie mache ich jetzt ein Computerspiel, sondern was will der, der das Brettspiel jetzt online spielt, eigentlich machen. Also ich bin nicht aus der Computerperspektive rangegangen, sondern aus der Brettspielperspektive. Und dann entscheiden die sich 2010 für eine 2D-Grafik. Und das ist super, weil es funktioniert.
Hat ja auch schon im wahren Leben funktioniert sozusagen. Warum nicht dann auch?
Und manchmal ist die 3D-Version schlechter zu spielen, auch im echten Leben, auch wenn ihr was hermacht. Muss man sich dann entscheiden zwischen Abverkäufe und zufriedene Kunden. Vielleicht verkauft man mit der 3D-Version mehr, aber sind die dann zufrieden? Nee. Insofern muss man es wirklich richtig machen. Man kann das nicht hinschludern. Und deswegen ist es unglaublich schwierig. Und bei Carcassonne hat es halt geklappt, weil das waren Klassiker. Ein moderner Klassiker. Das hatte schon so eine Marktdurchdringung. Und dann eine gute Umsetzung, das geht. Aber irgendein Spiel irgendwie umzusetzen, macht nicht so viel Sinn.
Es hängt natürlich immer davon ab, wie es gemacht ist. Und dass man das alles verkacken und vergeigen kann, das ist vollkommen klar. Ich meine, das sieht man ja auch. Na gut, der Vergleich jetzt mit Hollywood-Filmen und das Spiel dazu ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen weiter hergeholt, aber auch da mag es mal passen und mal nicht. Aber ich meine, auch ein Film hat ja im Prinzip erst mal keine Regeln. Das Spielelement ist da in der Regel so erst mal nicht vorhanden, aber es wird ja zumindest schon mal so eine Story gesetzt und damit auch eine Welt manchmal gebaut, in die man dann die Regeln und auch die Fantasie hineinprojizieren kann. Das kann eben gelingen und das kann nicht gelingen.
Also Lizenzspiele, wie man das dann nennt, also so eine Buchlizenz zum Beispiel, sind ja tendenziell eher schlechter als normale Spiele. Dass es überhaupt gute Lizenzspiele gibt, ist noch gar nicht so lange her. Also das Herr der Ringe, was ja kooperativ war, das wurde dann gelobt. Oh, ist es eine Lizenz und ein gutes Spiel. Also es war eher immer so ein Negativfaktor. Und auch bei Computer-Umsetzungen war es dann halt immer ja und die künstliche Intelligenz ist so schlecht und...
Können Bücher eine gute Vorlage sein? Oder ist das auch eher die Ausnahme?
Also als... Der Weg zum Spiel ist sehr weit. Gerade bei Büchern und Filmen. Weil normale Spiele gerade keine Story erzählen, die so fix ist. Und manche Spiele erzählen gar keine Story im dramaturgischen Sinne. Deswegen ist es sehr schwierig. Man muss es dann sozusagen skripten. Also da bestimmte Ereignisse auf jeden Fall irgendwie einbauen. Und das ist, glaube ich, schon hohe Kunst, was umzusetzen. Und irgendwie das Gefühl zu haben, es passt als Umsetzung. Weil ein Spiel so anders ist. Und weil das Ende ist ja auch offen. Also da kann eben Sauron gewinnen und nicht die Gefährten.
Skandal.
Skandal, genau. Wobei das ja noch nicht so schlimm ist. Aber bei Filmen hat man oft gewisse Plot Points und möchte Charaktere wieder treffen. Oder bei Büchern noch viel mehr. Es gibt ein paar Spiele zu Filmen, die gut funktionieren, oder zu Büchern, aber dann trotzdem nicht viel vom Film rüberbringen.
Wenn man jetzt irgendwie so ein bisschen dem Thema noch bisher so fern war, aber sich so denkt, man könnte ja jetzt auch mal wieder die Schachtel aus dem Regal ziehen, hat aber keine. Was sind denn so die Spiele, die man mal gespielt haben muss?
Jansila sollte man schon gespielt haben, obwohl ich das damals nicht mal mochte, als es rausgekommen ist. Das lag daran, dass ich mit einer bestimmten Person gespielt habe, die hat es einem verleidet. Also der Kontext hat nur die Hälfte der Regeln erzählt und dann Haushoch gewonnen, das zog sich und so. Der Kontext ist schon auch immer gut. Diese Klassiker sollte man spielen, also auch Carcassonne. Aber zum Beispiel, wenn man... Es fällt mir immer sehr schwer, denn es weiß fast keiner, aber es gibt so viele verschiedene Spiele, dass man eigentlich zu jeder Person ein Spiel finden kann, was gut zugeschnitten ist auf diejenige. Und die Tragik ist, die Händler in den Spielläden wissen meistens nichts. Also gerade in den großen, die sind nicht ausgebildet. Ich habe auch mal im Spielladen gearbeitet. Da muss man schon in so eine kleine Klitsche gehen, die es vielleicht in Studentenstädten gibt.
Gibt es denn so eine Brettspiel-Spezialistenbude irgendwo in irgendeiner Stadt, wo so die Freak sitzen?
Ja, es gibt eigentlich schon in den größeren Städten immer so Spezialistenbuden. Also ich hier in München jetzt nicht, da ist das Spezialisierteste der Oblätter oder es gibt dann schon wieder so kleine, die eher Tabletops machen und so.
Was ist das?
Tabletops sind so, jetzt darf ich nichts Falsches sagen. Wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, sind es so Spiele mit Miniaturen, die man auch bemalen kann und so und auf einer Landschaft und dann läuft man da so rum und beschießt sich oder was weiß ich oder kämpft. Das ist schon wieder eine andere Kultur.
Das ist mir schon so näher am Eisenbahnmodell sozusagen.
Ja, so eine Mischung zwischen Eisenbahnmodell und Spielen und Simulationen. Was man sonst so gespielt haben müsste, also wenn man sich ein bisschen mehr auskennt, dann ist Dominion schon eine schöne Wahl, was ja wie gesagt Spiel des Jahres war, 2009, ist aber vielleicht nicht so einfach für einen Einstieg. Also so ein Griff, ich sag das immer so ungern als Spieleautor selber, weil die ganzen Spiele keine Beachtung bekommen, die nicht das Spiel des Jahres kriegen. Aber so ein Griff zum Spiel des Jahres ist natürlich auch nicht doof.
Na gut, ich meine vielleicht gibt es da noch einen geheimen Tipp, der schon immer mal hätte das Spiel des Jahres werden sollen, aber die tun werden nicht.
Na ja, zum Beispiel Funkenschlag ist ein tolles Spiel. Da geht es darum Energiekonzerne aufzubauen und da kannst du auch deine Atomkraftwerke bauen und deine Fusionskraftwerk und deine Windkraftwerke. Das ist ein tolles Spiel, das war auch nie ein Spiel des Jahres.
Und wenn man alles richtig gemacht hat, explodiert das Atomkraftwerk und die Kühe fallen um?
Ja, den Sketch habe ich mal nachgespielt von L'Oréal. Dicky, sag ein Gedicht, zicke zacke Hühnerkacke. Ein sehr schönes Spiel. Da werden Spiele dann auch wieder in der Pop-Kultur verwendet. Es gibt unglaublich viele Monopoly-Satire. Ich habe letztens auch eine gesehen über das Webband. Aber das schaffen nur sehr wenige Spiele in diese Populärkultur einzugehen. Insofern fällt mir wirklich schwer, Empfehlungen zu geben. Wenn man mit Kindern spielt, was ein sehr schönes Spiel ist, war das Kinderspiel des Jahres. Letztes Jahr war es mit Elektronik lustigerweise. Es ist ein Deduktionsspiel, was ich ja schon erwähnt habe. Man muss herausfinden, wer den Diamanten-Ringen geklaut hat. Dann läuft man durch die Gänge. In den verschiedenen Räumen gibt es Tiere, die sagen einem Tipps. Das ist eine ganz schöne Vermischung zwischen einem Elektronikspiel. Du hast eine Box, die spricht halt, du sagst ja, wo du bist, und einem Deduktionsspiel gewesen. Eine der wenigen gelungenen Vermischungen zwischen Elektronik und Brettspiel.
Das ist auch so ein merkwürdiges Genre von Geräten, die man so drauf tippen muss. Zieht der Computer vielleicht mehr ins Brettspiel ein, als das Brettspiel in den Computer?
Ja, gerade mit den Touchgeräten kann ich mir das gut vorstellen. Aber das dauert alles noch ein bisschen, habe ich das Gefühl. Im Grunde wäre das jetzt die Zeit, wo jemand, der das richtig macht, wahrscheinlich die Brettspielbranche übernehmen könnte. Aber es macht halt keiner. Weil die Brettspielbranche hat auch viel zu wenig Geld. Also die Umsätze, die da gemacht werden, da lachen andere Branchen drüber. Das hat große Vorteile, so eine kleine Branche zu sein, weil viel über Vertrauen geht. Also da kommt man meistens nicht mit dem Anwalt, wenn irgendwas ist. Es wird auch kaum geklaut. Also ich zeige mit Klauen meine ich, ich zeige einem Verlag meine Idee. Und der sagt, das ist aber eine schöne Idee.
Können wir aber leider nicht machen.
Können wir nicht machen. Passt gerade nicht ins Programm. Passt erst, wenn sie aus der Tür rausgegangen sind.
Aber ist es denn auch so einfach, so etwas so gut umzusetzen? Ich meine, wenn man jetzt so die Idee erzählt, muss man sie dann soweit auspacken.
Meistens packt man dann schon ein fertiges Spiel aus und zeigt es.
Aber wenn man das jetzt kopieren wollte, dann müsste man ja auch noch eine Menge Gehirnschmalz reinstecken, um das wirklich zum Laufen zu bringen.
Die Anfänger beginnen ja immer damit, den Verlagen so eine Geheimhaltungserklärung hinzulegen. Daran erkennst du, der kennt sich in der Brettspiel-Branche nicht aus. Der kommt vielleicht von der Fernsehbranche oder so.
Ist das so ein Ehrenkodex oder warum funktioniert das?
Also es kennt sich jeder. Also da ist wieder das soziale Element das Wichtige. Man leistet es sich im Regelfall einfach nicht, weil das spricht sich dann wieder rum und dann kommen die Autoren nicht mehr zu mir, wenn ich das mache. Und überhaupt diese ganze Copyright-Schiene und Ideen-Clown ist sehr, sehr schön in der Brettspielbranche, ohne dass es Regeln dafür gibt. Das basiert alles auf diesen... Gentleman's Agreements, diesem Peer-Group-Verhalten. Wie verhalten sich die anderen? Also verhalte ich mich auch so. Das heißt, man kann eigentlich auch vertrauen anderen Spieleautoren und Spiele zeigen und mit denen testen, ohne Angst zu haben, dass sie das klauen. Natürlich werden sie davon inspiriert, aber ich inspiriere halt auch wieder andere. Und inspiriere mich von anderen Spielen. Und es gibt so eine unausgesprochene Regel, wenn ein Spiel erschienen ist, darf ich daraus alle Elemente benutzen. Ich sollte nicht das Spiel eins zu eins nachbauen, das würde auch kein Verlager nehmen, weil der sagt, das gibt es ja schon. Aber Elemente daraus nehme ich und baue die wieder anders ein bei mir. Diese Offenheit hat auch dazu geführt, dass die Brettspiele sich so weit entwickelt haben in den letzten 10, 20 Jahren. Wenn man bedenkt, wenn man Einzelsachen hätte patentieren können, dann wäre die Entwicklung wahrscheinlich nur ein Zehntel der Zeit.
So analog zu den Software-Patenten, dass man sagt, naja, ihr habt aber jetzt hier diese Art von Spielstein in diesem Spielkonzept verwendet. Das haben wir hier in unserem Spiel schon verwendet. Und das dürft ihr nicht...
Also entweder hätte sich dann so ein Austausch der Verlage herausgebildet, dass du eben Patente haben musst, damit du überhaupt ein Spiel machen kannst. So ein Patent-Tausch. Die ganze Kleinverlag-Szene wäre dadurch gar nicht entstanden, weil die hätten es sich nicht leisten können. Oder der ganze Prozess wäre viel langsamer abgelaufen. Und die Qualität der Spiele wäre viel langsamer gestiegen.
Denkst du, dass das auch etwas ist, was in der Szene komplett auch verstanden worden ist? Dass das so ein wichtiges Ding ist? Oder ist das eher nur so Zufall, dass noch keiner durchgedreht ist?
Ich glaube, dass viel in der Szene noch gar nicht verstanden wurde. Also was wir eigentlich hier tun und wie wichtig das sein könnte und wie nützlich für andere Bereiche. Das ist auch einer der Gründe, warum wir die Tarong gegründet haben. Um diese impliziten Sachen, die wir da machen, auch mal auszusprechen.
Wie viele Leute nehmen daran teil eigentlich?
Das sind nur 50 ungefähr.
Na ja, das ist schon eine Menge Leute.
Also 50 Autoren.
Räum schon voll.
Ja, also die Spieler-Autoren-Zunft, das ist sozusagen die...
Und das sind alle oder was?
Nein, das ist sozusagen die Gewerkschaft. Du musst da nicht drin sein. Aber du kannst drin sein und hast halt auch gewisse Vorteile. Du kommst auf die Messen. Das sind ungefähr 400 jetzt Leute. Aber es gibt natürlich noch mehr Spieler-Autoren weltweit. Aber es lässt sich schwer bemessen, weil viele auch nur ein einziges Mal was veröffentlichen.
Aber trotzdem gibt es ja auch ein Urheberrecht sozusagen. Wenn man jetzt so ein Spiel geschaffen hat, dann ist das irgendwie gesetzlich schon mal erkannt worden, was da einem zugeschrieben wird.
Also das ist ein schwieriges Feld.
Ist ja auch so ein bisschen wie Fernseh-Quiz-Shows entwickeln.
Wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, dann ist das eigentlich noch im Nebel des Grauens gefangen. Das heißt, wir wissen nicht genau, ob es ein Urheberrecht gibt. Und wollen es auch gar nicht so genau wissen.
Ich meine, es gibt ohne Zweifel ein Urheberrecht.
Ja, es gibt ein Urheberrecht, aber sind Spielregeln schützbar. Es ist auf jeden Fall schützbar, eine gewisse Ausformung, wie ich die Spielregeln lay-oute. Aber dieses Gedankenkonstrukt, ein Mechanismus, das geht ja eigentlich in die Richtung von einem Software-Patent, ist bei Spielen eigentlich nicht schützbar. Das heißt, wahrscheinlich könnte man hergehen und ein Spiel eins zu eins kopieren. Es macht nur keiner, weil man es halt nicht macht. Das ist ja auch in dieser ganzen Urheberets-Debatte genau der Knackpunkt. Beide Extreme führen ins Verderben.
Ich meine, wenn man es nicht macht, das funktioniert jetzt sozusagen in Deutschland. Aber was ist jetzt, wenn in anderen Ländern dieselben Spiele veröffentlicht werden, ohne dass da jetzt eine Lizenz gezogen wurde? Was ist ja gesagt, in den USA hat sich jemand die Lizenzen geholt. Gut, die Amerikaner machen das vielleicht automatisch, weil sie es nicht anders gewohnt sind.
Also es gab immer Raubkopien im Osten. Da Monopoly konnte ich mir nur selber nachbauen. Natürlich wurde da Monopoly gespielt.
Ach so, aber das war eher die Variante, die gezeigt hat, wie böse alles ist.
Nee, das hat man sich selber nachgebastelt. Und dann nach der Wende natürlich auch einfach die Raubkopien. Und das Lustige ist, dass eigentlich die Situation besser wird. Also wenn sich so ein Markt entwickelt und größer wird, dann kommen dann, also ich glaube, das gibt es in anderen Produktbereichen auch, dass erst so die Raubkopien da sind und wenn es dann so, genau den Markt schaffen und wenn es dann so integriert wird, dann holt man sich halt echte Lizenzen. Vielleicht auch, weil man denkt, man kann dann vor Gericht ziehen, selbst wenn es tatsächlich vielleicht nicht funktionieren würde. Also so ganz genau kann ich das persönlich gar nicht sagen, ob es geht oder nicht. Aber ja, wichtig ist eigentlich, dass da der gesunde Menschenverstand waltet. Das heißt, ich kopiere es dir nicht genau, aber ich lasse mich inspirieren und dafür darfst du meine Sachen wieder nutzen. Und das setzt viel Innovation frei.
Ja, und wo geht jetzt die Reise hin? Du hast ja gesagt, das ist alles jetzt noch ein sehr junges Objekt. Es tut sich viel, es werden sehr viele Spiele gemacht. Ich meine, wenn jetzt so viele Spiele gemacht werden, was hast du da gesagt, 300, 400. Und es gibt noch mehr Leute, die spielen oder zumindest die Spiele kaufen, als die, die es machen, also anders als in Italien. Das zeugt ja für mich dann auch so ein bisschen nach einem wachsenden Nachfrage.
Also der Markt ist stark in Deutschland, stark gewachsen in den 90ern, so diese Sieler-Zeit-Veröffentlichung. Und hat sich jetzt nicht mehr viel weiterentwickelt die letzten Jahre.
Also es gab einen Schub und der ist jetzt erstmal eingeflegt.
Es ist auch nicht rückläufig, aber es bleibt. Und die ausländischen Märkte wachsen. Das ist richtig. Es kommen immer mehr Länder dazu, die plötzlich Interesse dran haben. Es wird ja oft gefragt, ob die Computerspiele und die Brettspiele sich beißen. Ich glaube nicht, weil sie nochmal was anderes ansprechen. Also gemeinsam am Tisch sitzen und echte Materialien berühren. Das hat einfach ein anderes Flair und macht man auch zu anderen Anlässen.
Man nimmt sich auch Zeit.
Ja, man nimmt sich auch Zeit. Es ist immer ein gesellschaftliches Ereignis, so etwas zu tun. Manche spielen auch bloß, um zu kommunizieren, weil sie sonst nicht...
So wie der Skat, nicht wahr?...
wie langweilig werden oder gar nicht kommunizieren können. Oder so ist auch ein netter Füller. Der Anspruch an die Regeln ist natürlich auch anders. Und wo geht's hin? Es wird immer weiter verfeinert, möglichst viel verbessert und möglichst viel rauszuholen. Also es gibt einen Markt von strategisch anspruchsvollen Spielen, der aber relativ klein ist und so eine Mittelschicht, die vielleicht jeder verstehen kann, die sich aber auch wieder bedient aus diesen innovativen Mechanismen von den strategischen Spielen und versucht, die wieder ins einfache zu gießen. Also der Erfolg von Silla von Katarn war ja genau so was. Also diese Spiele, wo du Ressourcen hattest und dann was aufgebaut hast, die gab es ja vorher schon. Und er hat es einfach genommen und so weit eingedampft, wie es ging. Also populär gemacht. Reduktion. Also dieser Filterprozess, was Sperriges weiterzuentwickeln, populär zu machen, funktioniert bei Brettspielen auch immer. Und dann gibt es halt die Pioniere, die nicht immer den Ruhm abbekommen, leider, die sich was Neues ausdenken und das wird dann halt wieder aufgegriffen und setzt eine neue Welle los. Ich weiß nicht, ob die Art und Weise, wie Menschen miteinander interagieren, endlich ist. Wenn die endlich ist, dann wird es auch irgendwann keine Spiele mehr geben. Aber immer wieder neue Techniken zu finden, wie man miteinander was schaffen kann oder was tun kann, das ist eigentlich die Aufgabe der Spiele. Und Twitter zum Beispiel hätte eigentlich von einem Spieleentwickler stammen können. Weil diese Idee des asymmetrischen Verfolgens einfach eine sehr, sehr spielerische ist. Also ich abonniere dich, du aber nicht mich und welche Effekte dadurch entstehen. Es gibt ja auch sogar ein Belohnungssystem mit den Reetweets und mit dem Favstar. Das sind alles spielerische Aspekte. Und ich glaube, dass dieses Know-how aus den Spielen auch durchaus weiterleben wird in so Internet-Sachen oder Social Media, wo man es gar nicht erst merkt. Denn die spielerischen Aspekte von Farmville, die sieht jeder sofort, aber Farmville ist auch einfach bloß Zeitverdudeln. Die spielerischen Aspekte von Twitter sind ganz, ganz stark, aber die fallen den Leuten gar nicht auf. Ich hoffe, dass da wirklich das Know-how aus beiden Seiten mal zusammenkommt.
Meinst du sowas wie Twitter-Movie-Titles, wie würde ein Film heißen, wenn man ihn im Twitter-Version spielen würde? Meinst du sowas, solche Wortspiele, die man da miteinander spielt? Oder Blumenkübel-Memes, die...
Twitter ist ein Spielzeug. Das ist nützliches Spielzeug. Aber auch normale Spiele können nützlich sein, wenn ich jetzt ein Quiz-Spiel habe zum Beispiel, kann ich auch was lernen. Es gibt auch Lernspiele, einen großen Markt, wobei denen oft anhaftet, dass sie vielleicht nicht so viel Spaß machen. Man kann aber Spiele natürlich so entwickeln, dass sie Spaß machen. Ich träume immer noch und irgendwann, wenn ich mich auskennen würde, würde ich es tun, ein Brettspiel zu machen, das du spielst. Und wenn es fertig ist, hast du danach deine Steuer gemacht. Ohne dass du es überhaupt gemerkt hast.
Das wäre wirklich der höchste Grad an Nützlichkeit, den du mir vorstellen könntest.
Warum ich das nicht machen kann, ist, weil ich das nicht verstehe, was man alles absetzen kann. Also ich hätte die Expertise nicht.
Dann musst du dich hier mal mit den Steuerexperten zusammentun. Ich hatte ja auch hier auch neulich einen zu Gast.
Ich glaube, ja, das war eine fantastische Sendung. Bei dieser Sendung habe ich mir übrigens auch die ganze Zeit gedacht, wenn die ein bisschen spielerischer rangehen würden, würden sie das ganz anders machen.
Ja, ich meine, das betrifft ja auch Gesetze an sich. Diese ganzen Lücken ausnutzen, das ist ja nun gerade in der Steuergesetzgebung auch so ein echtes Thema. Vielleicht fehlt ja dem Gesetzgeber und der Juristerei an der Stelle auch einfach die notwendige Fantasie, wie man sie eben aus einer Spieleentwicklung heraus machen könnte. Vielleicht ist ja so spieltheoretisches Know-how auch die Basis der zukünftigen Gesellschaftsgestaltung. Ich übertreibe jetzt ein bisschen, ja, aber es sind natürlich solche Elemente. Und ich meine, deine vielleicht These, ob denn sozusagen der Themenbedarf und die Kommunikationsinteraktion irgendwie endlich ist, glaube, das kann man einfach getrost verneinen. Zumal ich auch glaube, dass natürlich auch ein Stück weit Gesellschaftsreflektion drin steht. Und wenn es nur dieses Monopoly ist, ja, vielleicht braucht man sowas auch, um irgendwie die Realität dann einfach auch mal so abzustreifen, wie das ja auch Computerspiele auch teilweise für einen erledigen. Und so mit den geänderten Kommunikationsverhalten, was wir da draußen an den Tag legen. Und das ändert sich ja nun wirklich in Windes Eile. Ja, Twitter mag da jetzt nur die aktuelle Speerspitze sein. Aber was schon allein Mobilfunk für Änderungen in unserem Sozialverhalten gemacht hat. Ich meine, wer hat das letzte Mal... Weißt du noch, wie es war, als man sich verabredet hat an einem Ort, als es keine Telefone gab? Also wie wichtig das dann war, wirklich zum richtigen Zeitpunkt auch da zu sein. Und heute ist so dieses, während man noch auf dem Weg ist, die SMS schreiben mit, naja, es wird zehn Minuten später und tralala, wir sind noch mal bei Italienerfeuer und kommt auch da vielleicht vorbei. Das ist ja jetzt irgendwie auch vollkommen normal. Ja, das ist irgendwie, das ist halt einfach so. Das macht man halt einfach so, weil man es eben kann. Also es gibt einfach genug gesellschaftliche Änderungen, die man auf der einen Seite verarbeiten muss, die man vielleicht auch im Spiel reflektieren möchte, um es für sich dann auch einfach greifbarer und begreifbarer zu machen. Aber andererseits vielleicht auch eben Dinge, mit denen man sich eben auch gerne im Spiel auseinandersetzen möchte, wo man dann auch Spaß daran hat, weil es eben etwas ist, was man aus dem normalen Leben eben kennt und darunter vielleicht leidet. Und wenn es nur das Wohl und Wehe in einem Internet-Startup ist, und in dem Moment, wo man das dann als Brettspiel spielt, dann ist man dann auch schon wieder beruhigt und kann dann irgendwie mit Spaß den Venture-Kapitalisten rausschmeißen. Oder was weiß ich, was man da psychologisch gerade verarbeiten muss.
Also das Blöde ist, dass Spiel und Ernst in unserer Gesellschaft ganz klar traditionell getrennt sind. Das heißt, wenn ich ein Spiel spiele, dann ist das nur Spaß und hat überhaupt keinen... das ist völlig für sich. Und wenn Ernst ist, ist Ernst. Und deswegen, wenn ich jetzt ein Spielsystem zum Beispiel nehme, um ein gesellschaftliches Problem zu lösen, dann kommen die Leute und sagen, aber das ist ja ein Spiel, das kann ja nicht funktionieren, das ist ja total albern. Ich kann ja meine Steuern nicht über ein Spiel verteilen. Also das wird gar nicht akzeptiert. Deswegen muss es eben machen, und deshalb benutze ich auch Twitter als Beispiel. Du musst diese Elemente einbauen, aber sag den Leuten nicht, dass es ein Spiel ist. Weil das wollen sie nicht.
Ich weiß nicht sehr viel darüber, aber es gibt ja den Begriff der Spieltheorie. Ich habe gerade mal Wikipedia aufgeschlagen, da ist schon der erste Absatz viel sagen. Die Spieltheorie ist sowohl ein Teilgebiet der Mathematik als auch der Soziologie, das sich damit befasst, Systeme mit mehreren Akteuren zu modellieren. Die Spieltheorie versucht unter anderem, das rationale Entscheidungsverhalten in sozialen Konfliktsituationen abzuleiten.
Ich möchte gegenüber der Spieltheorie etwas setzen, nämlich die Spielpraxis. Die machen die Spieltheorie, wir machen die Praxis. Und theoretisieren sie dann wieder. Die Spieltheorie hat das Problem, dass sie sich auf sehr einfache Sachen bezieht. Also sehr eindeutige Modelle des bekanntesten Gefangenen-Dilemma. Also zwei Gefangene wollen freikommen und werden einzeln befragt. Und sie können entweder den anderen anschwärzen oder auch nicht. Wenn ich den anderen anschwärze, der andere aber zu mir steht, dann bin ich befreit von aller Schuld und komme raus. Wenn wir uns beide nicht anschwärzen, dann kriegen wir fünf Jahre. Weil sie uns nichts nachweisen können, aber ein bisschen bestrafen muss ja sein in unserer Gesellschaft. Und wenn wir uns beide anschwärzen, dann wissen sie ja, wir sind beide schuld gewesen und kriegen zehn Jahre, weil wir ja das Verbrechen begangen haben. Was machst du? Mit solchen Fragen beschäftigt sich die Spieltheorie. Schwert sich den anderen an oder nicht? Und da ist es dann wichtig, wie viele Durchgänge wird dieses Spiel gespielt. In unserem Beispiel nur einmal. Also du hast nur einmal die Chance ihn anzuschwärzen oder nicht. Es könnte aber auch sein, es kumuliert sich. Ich kann ihn anschwärzen und dann noch den nächsten Kumpel und dann kumulieren sich die Jahre, die ich bekomme. Und da passieren unterschiedliche Sachen. Und damit beschäftigt sich die Spieltheorie. Hochspannend und eine riesen Enttäuschung für mich, weil sie so theoretisch bleibt. Das, was die sich da ausgedacht haben, das machen wir dauernd praktisch und lernen draus. Und kriegen ein Gefühl dafür. Und jetzt wird es langsam Zeit, dass wir das Wissen auch theoretisieren, um dann nutzbar zu machen. Also wir haben hier die große Ölquelle gefunden mitten in Deutschland, aber keiner hat Bock, sie anzuzapfen, weil man dann doch die Atomkraftwerke länger laufen lässt. Wir hatten da auch noch ein großartiges Spiel gespielt. Das war ein Testspiel, also das Spiel gab es noch nicht. Und da musste man so Waren ersteigern. Und das konnte man mit Geld machen. Und die Regeln waren so gebaut, dass man am Ende nur für die Waren, je nachdem, welche Waren man ersteigert hat, gewonnen hatte oder nicht. Also wenn ich ganz viele Rüben hatte, und ganz viele Tomaten hatte ich gewonnen. Ansonsten halt nicht. Das Geld war am Ende nichts wert. Man hat aber mit dem Geld diese Waren gekauft, von den anderen Spielern. Und der Witz an der Sache war, das Geld war nichts wert in dem Spiel. Weil es am Ende des Spiels nichts wert ist. Und bei einem Spiel zählt halt immer, wer gewonnen hat. Das heißt, de facto hatten wir ein Element in dem Spiel, was keinerlei Relevanz hatte für das Spiel selber. Es gab keinen Grund, dir jetzt für 10 Goldstücke meine Karotten zu geben. Weil mit den 10 Goldstücken konnte ich eigentlich nichts anfangen, weil die waren am Ende nichts wert. Man konnte auch nichts fest damit eintauschen. Und wir waren so trainiert, Geld als wertig zu empfinden, dass wir dieses Spiel ganz normal gespielt haben. Als hätte jedes Goldstück irgendwie einen Wert gehabt. Und da war ich am Ende total verblüfft, dass wir ein Spiel, eine Sache akzeptiert haben, als gegeben, die, wenn man sich die Mechanismen durchdenkt, einfach nur Blödsinn war. Also vom Spieldesign hat dieses Spiel gar nicht funktioniert. Weil das, womit man eigentlich um die Waren getauscht hat, das Beste wäre gewesen, meine Waren einfach gar nicht herzugeben. Meine Karotten für mich zu behalten und nicht zu sagen, du bietest mir 100 Scheine, die am Ende des Spiels nichts wert sind. Dann habe ich dann auch gedacht, ja, solche Sachen wie Geld, die können funktionieren, wenn die Leute dran glauben. Und so funktioniert ja Geld auch, dass die Leute dran glauben. Wenn keiner daran glauben würde, würde ich es nicht annehmen, sollte es nicht gehen. Deswegen bin ich auch immer skeptisch, wenn jemand nur mit Logik kommt und mir beweisen will, dass sowas kann nicht funktionieren. Also bei einem gesellschaftlichen System. Denn der Mensch ist immer mehr als Logik.
Du hast ja vorhin auch dieses Beispiel, mit dem jeder kriegt gleich viel Geld und dann kann man mit Grundeinkommen. Grundeinkommen ist ja auch so ein Ding, was sich auch so in Befürworter und Gegner teilt, die dann beide glühend jeweils das Gegenteil behaupten, kann nie funktionieren und wird irgendwie alle Probleme lösen. Siehst du denn eine Möglichkeit, dass man eben so dieses Spiele entwickeln mit Menschen, man kann ja das vielleicht auch mal vom Tisch, vom Brett wegkriegen und sozusagen auch Spielregeln in so einem begrenzten Menschenfeld mit richtigen Menschen über einen längeren Zeitraum machen, dass man eben sozusagen diese Spieleentwicklungslogik oder Methodik auch zum Überprüfen von solchen gesellschaftlichen Thesen herbeizieht?
Also das ist ja was im Internet gemacht wird. Da werden ja riesige Feldtests gemacht mit diesen ganzen Social Communities. Die können ja ihre Regeln festlegen und probieren da auch aus. Sie als Brettspiel zu entwickeln und dann dazu übertragen, das halte ich für sinnvoll. Es im Internet auszuprobieren ist aber wahnsinnig wichtig und eine riesige Chance. Und das finde ich unglaublich tragisch, dass die Politik noch in dieser Hinsicht den Wert des Internets noch nicht erkannt hat. Denn was wir im Internet ausprobieren, ist eigentlich kostenlos. Da gibt es keine Toten, wenn wir uns dumme Sachen ausdenken. Was haben die denn früher gemacht? Die haben sich die Marktwirtschaft am grünen Tisch ausgedacht. Natürlich mit ein paar Beispielen. Oder den Sozialismus oder den Kommunismus. Und haben das dann umgesetzt, ohne dass je ein Test gelaufen ist. Wir haben die große Chance, im Internet kann man schon mal sehen, funktioniert denn sowas? Also zum Beispiel Flatter als System. Man kann das einfach mal machen und sehen, wie reagieren die Leute.
Also Flatter, das Micropaymentsystem muss jetzt in ein paar Monaten...
Genau, also ich kann Geld einzahlen und das einfach verteilen. Und jetzt könnte man herkommen und sagen, okay, wir erklären das jetzt als Beta und schrauben ein bisschen rum und schauen, wie... Also es jetzt gar nicht so als das Tool sehen, als fertiges Tool, was jetzt benutzt wird, sondern einfach mal als Testinstrument, um zu gucken, wie reagieren Menschen auf bestimmte Regeln. Und ich glaube, dass man da viele Erkenntnisse auch gewinnen könnte. Auch dann fürs echte Leben. Und vielleicht sollten Gesetze auch in so eine Testphase erst mal gehen.
Ja, wobei, wenn es jetzt um Geld geht, ist es immer noch eine besondere Sache. Andererseits Geld ist auch mal was Interessantes. Also in dieser Diskussion um Flatter habe ich auch so den Eindruck gewonnen, gerade weil es Geld ist, drückt es sozusagen Zuneigung und Unterstützungsbereitschaft sehr viel besser aus als jetzt reine Akklamation. Ich behaupte jetzt mal, dass ich das toll finde. Aber wenn es darauf ankommt, dann sähe es ganz anders aus. Ähnlich ist es ja auch mit diesen Delphi-Börsen, diesen Vorhersagesystemen, wo dann Leute quasi auf das Eintreffen eines bestimmten Ereignisses wetten mit richtigem Geld. Und es hat sich immer wieder gezeigt, dass wenn Geld im Spiel ist, wenn die Leute was zu verlieren haben, dass sie an der Stelle dann eben auch sehr ehrlich sind und dann tatsächlich kollektiv in der Lage sind, als Massenphänomen dann auch relativ gut zutreffende Voraussagen zu bilden. Das ist ja eigentlich auch ein Spiel.
Ja, das ist auch ein Spiel. Und es ist auch wichtig bei Brettspielen oder bei Spielen allgemein, sich anzusehen, was ist das Ziel des Spielers? Was will der eigentlich? Denn je nachdem, was er will, funktioniert das Spiel völlig anders ab. Wenn ich jetzt ein Spiel habe, wo es um die Siegpunkte geht, die ich am Ende habe, also ich nenne sie immer Siegpunkte, das hat sich so eingebürgert, das sind einfach Punkte, die man aufschreibt oder die...
Was auch immer sozusagen den Sieg ausdrückt.
Genau. Und wer die meisten davon hat, gewinnt halt. Dann verhält sich das völlig anders, als wenn es um den Platz geht. Bin ich erster, zweiter oder dritter? Mein Verhalten im Spiel wird ganz anders sein. Ich werde andere Strategien für fahren, weil da geht es dann um alles oder nichts. Werde ich erster oder werde ich nicht erster? Als er erster, zweiter oder dritter war falsch, werde ich erster oder nicht erster, wenn es nur Sieg und Verlust gibt. Oder in einem Aktionsspiel, wo ich malen muss, ist mir vielleicht wichtiger, dass die Runde mich toll findet, dass ich witzig bin, weil ich danach eben...
Die Metaebene.
Genau. Dann werde ich ganz anders spielen, als wenn ich auf die Siegpunkte spiele. Oder der Klassiker bei Brettspielen. Vielleicht lasse ich meine Freundin gewinnen, wenn ich danach noch Sex haben will. Es gibt Leute, die tun das. Und dann ändert sich das Spielverhalten.
Aber was ist denn mit Geld?
Und bei Geld ist es genau das. Geld verändert das Spielverhalten sehr, wenn es um Geld geht. Wir kennen das ja auch von Poker, wenn es um Geld geht.
Das ist ja nur ein Kartenspiel, hast du gesagt. Das zählt für dich auch bei Brettspiele. Poker ist ja an der Stelle das klassische Geldverteilungs-Game. Was spielt das für eine Rolle? Ich habe mir nachgedacht, mit Geld zu arbeiten.
Nee, da das jetzt auch nicht erlaubt ist, wie ich...
Ist es nicht?
Ich denke, irgendwann war das mal nicht erlaubt. Ja, aber das dann zu produzieren.
Ach so, ja, okay.
Das macht dann keinen Spaß, wenn es nicht erlaubt ist.
Na gut, man kann ja seine Plastichips auch irgendwie gegen Münzen austauschen.
Ich glaube, da muss man wieder nachweisen, dass es kein Glücksspiel ist. Ich glaube, dass ich so gewinnen kann. Vielleicht brauche ich dann auch noch ein Lied. Ach, keine Ahnung. Das ist mir zu kompliziert.
Das Fass müssen wir jetzt auch nicht unbedingt drauf machen.
Ja, Geld verändert das schon sehr. Weil du es ernster nimmst. Es kommt einfach eine neue Ebene rein. Weil dieses Geld bedeutet etwas nach dem Spiel. Bei einem Brettspiel ist es normalerweise so, am Ende ist alles vergeben und vergessen. Du trägst nicht nach, was im Spiel geschehen ist. Im Spiel darf ich mich aufhören wie ein Troll, wenn ich das möchte. Ohne dass du es mir nachtragen willst.
In der Wirklichkeit schaffen das nicht alle.
Die umgeworfenen Spielbretter sind Legion. Deswegen ist es wahrscheinlich auch verboten, spitze Gegenstände in die Spiele zu tun, weil sonst jemand umkommen könnte dabei.
Wer sich mal vergegenwärtigen will, da fällt mir gerade noch ein schöner, klassischer Film ein. Der Krieg der Knöpfe. Kennst du den? Wo diese Kinderbanden irgendwie gegeneinander spielen und der Gewinner knöpft dann den anderen im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes die Knöpfe ab, sondern dann haben die halt keine Knöpfe mehr, die dann in den Hosen runterrutschen usw. Große Schwach, große Scham irgendwie.
Und wenn du jetzt Brettspiele aufs echte Leben übertragen willst, dann musst du halt sehen, dass es nicht nur Geld gibt, sondern zwei Mechanismen, die Ziele sein können. Das ist Geld und Boom bzw. Aufmerksamkeit. Und durch die Social Media merkt man eben, wie arg Aufmerksamkeit ein Motivationsfaktor ist. Ich glaube, das ist auch der große Fehler, warum bislang die meisten dynamischen Systeme eben so kranken. Weil diese Aufmerksamkeit und dieser Fame einfach nicht mit berücksichtigt wurden. Also ich kann die tollsten mathematischen, physikalischen Beschreibungen haben, wie sich Wasser verhält. Wenn ich nicht daran denke, dass das auch zu Eis werden kann, bringt mir das halt nichts. Weil in einem anderen Zustand verhält sich es dann wieder anders. Also so findet man kein vollständiges System. Deswegen muss man die Motivation, wenn ich ein Brettspiel entwickle, der Spieler auch mit berücksichtigen, warum spielen die das? Was wollen die eigentlich erreichen damit? Und wenn ich das nicht tue, dann macht das keinen Spaß. Und das ist der Todesstoß für ein Brettspiel. Und das ist, glaube ich, der Grund, warum Brettspiele so gut sind. Weil sie die Freiwilligkeit des Spielers voraussetzen. Dass er sich freiwillig in das System begibt.
Und am Ende zählt der Spaß?
Am Ende zählt der Spaß, ja. Was anderes zählt nicht.
Ja Marcel, das war jetzt aber schon ein langer Ritt hier durch die Brettspielwelt. Ich denke, wir haben ja irgendwas ganz Entscheidendes unerwähnt gelassen.
Also ich denke, die ganzen Fragen, die ich nicht beantwortet habe, sind die Fragen, die einem Brettspiel-Entwickler immer gestellt werden. Und da gibt es viele Quellen im Netz, um die zu beantwortet zu bekommen.
Warte mal, ich habe jetzt die ganzen klassischen Fragen nicht gestellt?
Ja, wie kommst du dazu, wie macht man das und wo verkauft man das?
Ach so, das können wir den anderen überlassen.
Das können die anderen klären, ja.
Genau, wir haben uns ja mal über die Metaebene unterhalten. Das ist ja hier auch sehr angemessen.
Ja, ich danke auch.
Das war eine interessante Reise. Und euch da draußen, hoffe ich, hat das auch ganz gut gefallen. Ja, ich packe jetzt hier gleich wieder meine sieben Sachen. Und dann geht es wieder zurück nach Berlin. Und da warten auch schon neue Podcast-Termine auf mich. Es geschieht jetzt gerade mal wieder ein bisschen mehr hier im Programm bei Chaos Radio Express. Ich freue mich, dass ihr zugehört habt und auch immer wieder einschaltet und mich auch sonst immer so fleißig unterstützt und motiviert und mit guten Ideen beliefert. Ja, dann machen wir jetzt hier mal den Topf zu. Das war's. Tschüss und bis bald bei Chaos Radio Express.